chronique
va jouer avec les pièces blanches pour
la dixième partie du match toujours
avantage chronique
Kasparov n'a pas réussi à passer il a
fait un essai ce weekend en revenant
avec E4 sur la défense berlinoise avec
les Noirs samedi il a posé de gros
problèmes à krani que va-t-il se passer
aujourd'hui crânique va-t-il calmer le
jeu ou a-t-il préparé quelque chose
contre la défense nimzowitch de Kasparov
c'est la question et chronique démarre
tout de suite avec le coup des quatre
que va jouer Kasparov il peut jouer la
défense
nimzowitch ou le gambidam deux
possibilités pour transparence il
choisit a priori kf6 on va revoir
probablement
une défense nimzowitch oui C4 de
cramique le coût de Kasparov s'il
revient sur la partie de samedi il va
jouer E6 et oui il joue pareil pour
l'instant castroff effectivement
il va venir ici Kasparov
dans la défense inovic est-ce que krani
va jouer le coup cavalier C3 ou va
changer va-t-il changer pour le coup
cavalier 3 il peut jouer les deux
sans le C a-t-il préparé une
amélioration de sa partie il vaut mieux
d'ailleurs de samedi parce que kaspard
aurait été peut-être même
en gros avantage car elle est C3
oui c'est la même partie à quel moment
cramique va-t-il dévier ici
cramique avait joué je crois le coup
d'Anne c'est deux si je me rappelle bien
il avait joué le coup de la dame en C2
si on peut montrer les chic et
démonstration ici il avait joué la dame
ici sur la case C2 vous voyez la petite
flèche verte voilà le coup qui avait
joué cramique que va-t-il jouer cette
fois-ci
la chronique réfléchit
chronique réfléchit il peut jouer
d'autres coups sont possibles
F3 probablement
et non il joue le coup E23 chronique
probablement
qui veut encore
une fois de plus ne pas permettre à
casses paroles
de jouer les variantes qu'il a préparé à
chaque fois chronique des vies le
premier
il empêche à chaque fois les variations
de casse-parov il ne veut pas rentrer
dans les préparations de casse-parents
il y a jamais de débat crânique ne veut
pas le débat théorique il veut jouer les
parties sur les chéquier il ne veut pas
les préparations de Kasparov à la maison
voilà alors que Edward Hollande nous
rejoint
bonjour Stéphane bonjour à tous et
bienvenue pour ce superbe affrontement
gare Vladimir cramique alors que les
deux joueurs sont en train de réfléchir
déjà les deux joueurs sont en train de
réfléchir on va casse-parents ici un
problème puisque là kanik a dévié il a
pas joué damso2 il a joué au 2e
effectivement une fois de plus surprend
en premier on prend la bonne remarque
E3 c'est un coup bah c'est le coup
principal en fait c'est le coup qui
était joué Zurich 53 surtout donc ça
fait plus de 50 ans que ça existe ici
effectivement le coût E3 au lieu du coup
marqué en rouge c'est ce qu'avait joué
cramique et il a choisi le coup E23 et
donc le problème c'est que kasporama
devait s'attendre à la même variante et
on va préparer sûrement de grosses
défenses là-dessus cramique à chaque
fois le surprend encore une fois la
cramique est capable évidemment de jouer
indifféremment de MC2 ou E3 il y a pas
de problème pour lui
E3 c'est un coup très très principal
mais un peu démodé depuis que MC2 a été
remis à la mode bon maintenant
effectivement E3 pourquoi pas je veux
dire c'est dans les vieux pots qu'on
fait de la bonne soupe Stéphane
la cramique joue un coup moins usité peu
de 3 mais qui contient sa part de venin
aussi alors est-ce que cramique va jouer
pour faire nul aujourd'hui ou va quand
même encore toujours essayer de gagner
alors chronique effectivement quand on
dispose des pièces blanches rappelons-le
on a un avantage Stéphane donc
effectivement chronique à mon avis ne va
pas lâcher Gary caspov puisque pour
l'instant il était sous pression dans
les deux dernières parties la première
envie de revenir un petit peu de
remettre qu'est-ce-que
tout à fait c'est très logique on met le
droit à l'abri bon pas de problème
Erica sparov en fait il a réfléchi sport
tout simplement pour se rappeler ce qui
connaissait puisque évidemment il est
très familier avec cette position il a
joué avec les Blancs 3 très souvent il y
a pas de il y a pas de souci il y a un
casse pas en fait cramique connaisse
très bien de toute façon on va montrer
l'échiquet de démonstration
ici le plan des Noirs qui viennent de
mettre le roi ici G8 à l'abri en mettant
la tour en jeu et bien le plan des Noirs
c'est de contrôler les cases au centre
les cases de cases blanches puisque le
fou ici attaque le cavalier et on voit
que le roi est derrière donc on peut pas
bouger ce cavalier ce cavalier ne
contrôle pas les cases blanches
centrales alors que le cavalier en F6
lui contrôle ses cases alors Stephen
contre le ventes E3 c'est pas tout à
fait pareil l'enjeu de la position
puisque ici les Blancs ont préparé ont
prévu de jouer avec F3 pour contrôler
bien les cases blanches fout des trois
qui est ge2f3 l'enjeu c'est surtout
l'explosion du centre ici normalement
les Noirs jouent au dessin qui est C5
essayons de chercher à échanger tous les
pions centraux alors ça on va montrer
donc cette c'est important cette
possibilité
il va falloir que les Blancs s'il joue
F3 c'est bien qu'il y a une lutte pour
qu'elle blanche qui cache blanche qui
est instaurée alors les noirs peuvent
pas lutter donc ils vont jouer plutôt
ces cinq
pour exploser le centre ici créant des
tensions sur les plans en les pions
blancs centraux oui pourquoi tout
simplement parce que ils sont mieux
développés des Noirs dans cette position
ils ont donc envie d'ouvrir le centre
crânique chou-foute très logique pas mal
travaillé
CE2 Stéphane pour renforcer le cavalier
en C3 et ensuite chasser le fouet 4
alors c'est un peu trop technique et
voilà ce que tu nous dis là alors après
dessiner quelque chose alors là
peut-être Caspar of menace tout
simplement de prendre ces quatre et le
fou son obligé de reprendre les Blancs
ont perdu un temps peut-être normalement
on prend ces quatre à peu près quand on
veut puisque les blancs eux ne menacent
pas de prendre en dessin c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une tension qui est un petit
peu je dirais d'un seul côté si les
blancs prennent c'est pas bon puisque
après eux prend on a ouvert la diagonale
du foot C8 en donc en revanche les noirs
peuvent prendre quand ils veulent donc
ils sont pas pressés ici normalement
cramique devrait jouer quel jeu de voir
pas de souci de démonstration voilà le
plan que loi est en train de nous
indiquer le cavalier ici j'ai un phase
développer faut rappeler que aux échecs
les lois on développe ses pièces et on
fait le petit on fait le rock très
rapidement et non il jouait Curie F3 que
le F3 bon c'est c'est l'autre coup qui
avait G2 était plus à la mode 3 c'est
vraiment Stéphane c'est les variantes de
Zurich 53 le fameux tournoi le plus long
de l'histoire rappelant Éloi que
Kasparov a perdu la rare par la seule
partie du parti lent qu'il a perdu
depuis longtemps c'était l'année
dernière je crois au tournant des Candy
contre sokolof et c'était sur une
vieille variante justement en janvier 99
donc il y a un bout de temps et c'était
exactement sur cette vente là d'ailleurs
avait joué c'est 5 c'était exactement
cette défense in the beach c'était
pareil la même défense la même défense
la même ouverture et Sokolov c'était une
surprise parce que sokolof c'était pas
ah petit rock c'est pas carpov petit
rock c'est 5 voilà tout ça c'est c'est
voilà c'est bon c'est normal la
catastrophe devrait jouer qui est C6
alors autant évidemment pour l'instant
mais pas de pas de grosse menace puisque
il y a quatre minutes de dépenser pour
chaque joueur je vous rappelle que les
joueurs ont deux heures chacun pour
jouer les 40 premiers coups la casse par
off en grosse réflexion en train de
prier que sparovarovs
qui est en train de prier Allah ça y est
on assiste
évidemment juif donc il prépare là donc
il prie plutôt Jéhovah alors voilà ça
doit être ça mais effectivement la
Kasparov il commence tout de suite à
nous mettre oulala il s'est endormi sur
l'échiquier le pauvre castor
il est quand même excellent
mais il va pas arrêter il va pas arrêter
pendant tout le match d'éviter mes
préparations
c'est pas le coup principal Stéphane tu
reprends des quatre ça pose tout de
suite la question au blanc c'est un coup
homo cramique lui se pose pas de
question en fait et c'est un pion isolé
qui ont isolé alors on va expliquer tout
de suite
pas pris dans ces quatre d'ailleurs tout
de suite Stéphane on peut le montrer
vas-y après
ça joue très vite bah c'est l'ouverture
c'est normal les joueurs connaissent
bien et bien on se retrouve dans la même
variante des lois euh voilà ça joue trop
vite cette ouverture ça joue trop vite
alors qu'on nous signale voilà l'arbitre
vient de venir nous voir pour nous dire
de parler moins fort Stéphane de fermer
la porte surtout nous allons être obligé
malheureusement de fermer cette porte ou
alors de parler moins fort ce qui est
possible aussi c'est au choix ce qui est
au choix donc on va essayer de parler un
peu moins fort alors donc là après B6
ici
de Kasparov alors l'idée c'est collé
blanc ici on tombe tout seul mais qu'il
a pas d'homologue sur les colonnes CD à
côté pour le soutenir
donc ce pion menace
alors que nous allons en fait fermer la
porte Stéphane
voilà
je vous rappelle ici nous sommes dans un
conduit
qui fait 1 m² et que c'est pas facile
voilà c'est bien le c'est même assez
délicat mais enfin ce n'est pas grave
donc là ça joue très très bien
7 et les deux joueurs se sont levés
maintenant Stéphane ça y est les deux
sont partis ça c'est superbe
est parti également encore une fois
plein de la scène où il y avait pas
aucun des deux joueurs mais chronique
est revenu avec son fameux verre d'eau
il a l'air il a l'air en bonne forme
chronique je le sens bien déterminé ben
là en fait il a une version avantageuse
de ce qu'il a vu dans la partie
précédente je crois Stéphane puisque son
pion est encore en a deux et non pas en
A4 ce qui joue il y a pas
d'affaiblissement c'est un pion isolé
parfait alors c'était quelle partie
c'était la sixième partie 6e partie ou
chronique avait on va montré les chiquer
de démonstration
avec déjà ce fameux pion isolé voilà le
pion ici central qui est tout seul
par aucun autre pion blanc et les Noirs
vont essayer de contrôler activement la
case des 5 pour empêcher ce pion
d'avancer à noter que le gros problème
pour les Noirs évidemment pour l'instant
c'est le kvb8 on ne sait pas trop
comment l'améliorer s'il vient en D7 et
bien le contrôlera d'autant moins la
caisse des 5 voilà c'est très
importantes alors les blancs peuvent
menacer de le jouer des 4 dessins qu'à
tout moment
et effectivement c'est une position que
les deux joueurs connaissent très bien
puisque je crois que Kasparov l'ajout
avec les Blancs et avec les noirs et
cramique aussi donc en fait là on est
sur une sorte de terrain spécialisée
pour tout le monde les deux joueurs
connaissant très très bien cette
position évidemment normalement les
blancs sont un petit peu mieux et
cramiques à mon avis va jouer 20
poursuivre le combat aussi longtemps qui
pourra effectivement elle est cramique
de toute façon je pense qu'on peut dire
qu'on est avec toi
non mais là on espère que surtout il y
aura du beau jeu si castarof arrive à
trouver quelque chose et bien
ça va être très bien aussi
on espère simplement que ça va mettre le
feu sur l'échiquier quel que soit ce que
trouve les uns les autres là c'est sûr
encore les doigts on a une partie
dissymétrique et donc ça amène forcément
du Beaujeu c'est clair le feu isolé
c'est toujours très très sport dans la
mesure où alors par contre les Noirs ont
un avantage temporel c'est-à-dire si la
partie vient se prolonger en maintenance
cette configuration et bien ça sera bien
pour les Noirs puisque les blancs on
fait des concessions positionnelles en
revanche et bien s'il est blanc arrive
très vite par un jeu dynamique en jouant
par exemple cavalier au 5 effectivement
la fameuse attaque sur le roi comme on
l'avait fait
une pression dans le camp noir
importante il y a beaucoup de
possibilités pour les blancs voilà une
bonne possibilité donc les blancs dans
cette configuration de pions isolés
sur la tour à 8 alors on va montrer
cette variante si le fou ici en B7 prend
le cavalier F3 et bien tout simplement
la dame en des reprend et ça attaque la
tour qui est en A8 là c'est de Tours ici
donc il faut que le noir protège et donc
le pion des 4 n'est pas en prise voilà
tout à fait donc ici pour l'instant
Garric sport réfléchit bon pour
l'instant bilan pendule quand même
Stéphane les joueurs ont joué très vite
puisqu'ils ont réfléchit à peu près 5
minutes chacun pour jouer les 11
premiers coups il joue vite là il joue
très vite et là on va peut-être avoir
droit maintenant un peu de réflexion
côté joueurs peut-être connaissent
excellent alors on a l'impression depuis
samedi dernier qu'on a non plus du jeu
je dirais instantané mais on a du jeu
préparé à la maison oui beaucoup plus de
préparation dans cette fin de match au
début c'était plus intuitif les joueurs
prenaient un peu la mesure il prenaient
un petit peu la teneur de la garde
adverse mais découvrez en fait ils
découvrez les choix de l'adversaire et
maintenant effectivement on a on assiste
beaucoup plus à des préparations maison
les jours sont plus chauds et bah
surtout Stéphane les parties deviennent
très très cher maintenant puisqu'il en
reste de moins en moins et Gary castor
fait toujours mené au score le match est
en train de se jouer dans les parties à
venir donc il y a beaucoup plus de
tension et donc c'est beaucoup plus
chaud pour les joueurs
alors
faut faire très intéressant le Titan de
la planète échec champion du monde
depuis 15 ans on peut le on peut le
rappeler quand même comme d'habitude
c'est quand même un phénomène un vrai
monstre ce gars par off et Vladimir
cramnik lui le petit jeune de 25 ans
l'idée très calme très cool et pour
l'instant il prend l'avantage il semble
mieux jouer tout simplement que Gary
Kasparov c'est tout à fait exceptionnel
ce qui se passe quasiment champion du
monde depuis 15 ans deuxième plus long
règne du jeu d'échec après celui
d'Emmanuel lasquer 27 ans 27 ans c'était
un record absolu à noter quand même qu'à
l'époque Emmanuel lacher choisissait
lui-même ce challenger ce qui lui a
permis donc de durer plus longtemps tel
une pile Duracell Stéphane
que je trouve ça alors là c'est
technique c'est plutôt ton sujet moi
l'histoire des échecs a priori ne
m'intéresse pas spécialement je suis
plutôt échec moderne plutôt Gary
Kasparov Vladimir cramique et Vichy
Manhattan qui n'est pas là ici puisque
c'est le match entre les deux meilleurs
joueurs de la planète
il nous fait des pauses de réflexion
totalement intenses en ce moment il est
très concentré il gigote tu vois il est
là gigote un peu dans tous les sens Gary
parce qu'on disait c'est que quand ça
rend fessait de capturer le cramique qui
pour l'instant batifold dans le champ de
maïs et il n'arrive pas à l'attraper
alors ça c'était une image effectivement
intéressante c'est caspero force sniper
dans la jungle qui qui voit le kramnique
du haut de ses 2 mètres qui déborde un
peu du champ de blé et qui essaie de le
calibrer de le imposer en fait
n'arrive pas à l'avoir et donc il
faudrait peut-être qu'il pense envoyer
les chiens pour le sortir du champ en
tout cas il faut rappeler que castaro
fait quand même venu avec sa mafia la
mafia russe
ils sont venus à plusieurs ici pour
essayer de contrer cramique petite
remarque comme sur les seconds de Gary
Kasparov il s'agit non seulement de
Grand Maître d'échecs mais également
d'excellents boxeurs Stéphane puisqu'ils
sont tous une carrure d'enfer et on n'a
pas envie de les faire chier
extrêmement chauds
le retour du parrain en tout cas
cramique n'a pas peur cramique il est il
est assez tranquille il est pas du tout
intimidé ni par les mimiques ni par les
coups ni par les gardes du corps de
castarov il est tout à fait
impressionnant Vladimir crannique très
très serein à noter quand même que dans
le camp cramique il y a Joël Lothier le
numéro en français qui fait du kung fu
puisqu'il est vietnamien d'origine je
crois son père japonaise son père est
français mais effectivement il fait
beaucoup d'arts martiaux beaucoup de
forges
une certaine sérénité qui se laisse pas
intimidés par-ci peut alors comme on
sait peut-être la position
parce que là on a un peu dévié alors là
position donc très tendue alors on vous
rappelle le pion isolé c'est ce
ici donc pion isolé bloqué sur la case
des 5 les Noirs eux ont simplement deux
îlots de pions je sais pas si je peux le
montrer alors comment
je monte en jaune voilà deux îlot pions
les pions assez de B6 et les pions E6 F7
G7 et F7 deux îlots donc c'est plus
compact c'est plus difficile à attaquer
avantage pour les blancs de cette
position c'est l'espace il faut avoir
plus d'espace et notamment la case 5 que
tu citais tout à l'heure le cavalier ici
F3 peut sauter sur cette case oui alors
avantage quand même pour les blancs
c'est que le cavalier F6 pour l'instant
est cloué ça c'est assez ennuyeux alors
je vais enlever toutes ces flèches parce
que là il faut nettoyer Stéphane il faut
nettoyer c'est un peu de nettoyage voilà
après cette explication alors qu'il y a
plus simple il faudrait faire comme ceci
et revenir à la fin de la partie voilà
c'est pas mieux c'est donc nettoyer et
ici le fou G5 bloque le cavalier F6 le
cavalier ce qui est quand même l'unique
défenseur autour du roi noir ce cavalier
ici protège ici le camp le camp noir et
il peut pas bouger puisque sinon le fou
prendrait la dame alors donc ça donne
pas mal d'idées d'attaque notamment on
peut indiquer un plan très simple pour
cramique c'est cavalier 5 dans un
premier temps alors une plante très
simple on va on va on montre non non on
va pas entre les cons on va juste
montrer le plan on va montrer le plan
donc ici le 3 viendrait en 5 la tour
viendrait sur la case 3 la tour 1
viendrait sur la case E3 puis sur la
case H3 puis sur la case H3 ici pour
viser le noir voilà c'est ça peut
revenir en Détroit bref toutes les
pièces blanches sont prêtes à venir
participer à cette attaque le fou ici il
reviendrait éventuellement sur la case
des trois pour attaquer le pion HD voilà
oui ça c'est un plan d'attaque c'est les
plans très classique évidemment Gary
kasporov est en train de réfléchir pour
se prémunir contre ce genre d'idée il
n'a jamais pris l'attaque aussi violente
que c'est très rare donc c'est pas grave
c'est un joueur d'attaque lui-même donc
il aime c'est pas un très bon joueur de
défense enfin bien se faire il n'aime
pas se faire attaquer faut pas exagérer
non plus garer Casper peut défendre oui
il peut le faire mais il préfère quand
même largement avoir l'initiative
largement jouer l'attaque ici là la
migraine est en pleine réflexion est-ce
qu'on peut le voir peut-être en gros
plan le volant on a montré donc ce plan
évidemment castorov peut tout à fait
empêcher ce plan par plein de moyens
il va poser des problèmes au blanc
la gari il est en pleine réflexion et il
a pas l'air très emballé par sa position
Stéphane un peu peur
je suis sûr que il est hors préparation
HP cramique
encore une fois à éviter en fait la
réalité de relancer le débat il n'aime
pas relancer le débat cramé qui préfère
c'est son mais je crois qu'il a déjà dit
il préfère réfléchir sur l'échiquier
alors c'est pas tout à fait ça en fait
puisque rappelons quand même que dans
les 8 premières parties du match c'est
passe qui a changé systématiquement
c'est vrai et régulièrement dans les
deux dernières c'est cramiques qui
changent on a l'impression que
maintenant il a plus envie de laisser à
castor of la parole au niveau de la
préparation dans les ouvertures il lui
maintenant Gary tu te calmes je ne joue
plus rien que tu connais si on joue aux
échecs tout simplement et là c'est là
que cramique espère tenir notons quand
même Stéphane que si cramique finit par
sinule puisqu'il reste non il reste 7
parties si il fait 7 nulle et bien il
sera champion du monde avec 15 nuls et
un gains alors je pense que la nouvelle
si c'est pas comme ça c'est pas que
cramique sera champion du monde c'est
surtout que kasparoff le sera plus
effectivement
il suffit pas de battre castor pour
prouver qu'on bat tous les autres et
pour cramer que le problème est de et
d'actualité puisqu'il reste encore à
battre à Nantes et chirof de joueurs qui
n'a jamais battu que kasporf lui bas
systématiquement donc en fait
partie enfin je veux ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui n'a pas battu en match et
contre qui n'a pas d'espoir
impressionnants on casse pas offre
contre le numéro 3 mondial qui avait
Michel Manhattan à Nantes hymen sur le
score de 18 victoires à 3 quelque chose
comme ça ce qui est un score éloquant
effectivement donc en fait le moralité
sikramnik bac asparov il aura prouvé que
kasporov n'est pas le meilleur joueur du
monde tout ce qui aura prouvé non leur
approuvé qu'il est capable de battre
kasparo fait match n'est pas imbattable
voilà enfin en tout cas c'est clair que
80 ne sera plus considéré comme champion
du monde étant donné que une très belle
il a le nez
congestionné Garric la pause
a quelques cheveux blancs mais ça ça
fait longtemps il faut dire que genre
d'échec il y a quand même énormément de
travail et on vieillit prématurément
forcément à force de travailler 15
heures par jour pendant 10 ans oui
d'ailleurs faut rappeler que là
c'est ce qui est très étonnant puisque
j'ai beaucoup travaillé j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
donc j'ai grandi très vite non non mais
c'est vrai que Gary fait du produit un
effort tellement énorme dans son match
contre carpov en 85 le fameux match qui
avait duré 6 mois ça a dû lui un
coup
à quoi va-t-il réfléchir alors qu'avez
les 17 c'est possible mais
là
tu as trouvé le coup de guerre
il fallait développer le cavalier le
problème c'est que quand tu me disais
tout à l'heure c'est que la casse des 5
n'est plus protégée et que les Blancs
pourraient éventuellement pousser des
quatre dessins on peut l'envisager tout
de suite dans cette position Stéphane
alors là pour cramique voilà l'idée
c'est de protéger le cavalier et en cas
de prise du fou mais on prend pas du
pion on va prendre la tour ça dépend ça
dépend si on a joué des cinq ou pas
alors c'est au choix s'il prend du fou
on peut reprendre soit du pion soit de
la tour
que toutes les pièces blanches sont
développées toutes les pièces noires
aussi sauf la tour à 8 mais qui va
peut-être jouer tour C8 parce que pour
l'instant disons que les Noirs ont une
position très solide comme on peut le
voir toujours pas de faiblesse les
pièces toutes bien sorties alors après
tour C8 qui va probablement suivre qui
est une possibilité
et si
et bien toutes les pièces quasiment des
deux côtés auront été développés oui
alors le gros problème pour les Noirs
dans cette position Stéphane on peut le
dire c'est la Dame des 8 qui ne sait pas
trop où aller parce que elle est bouchée
par le pion B6 elle peut pas sortir par
là ouais et de l'autre côté on sait pas
trop ce qu'elle ferait sur ces cases là
oui la mettre en 8 ça n'a pas de sens la
mettre en E7 c'est terrible parce
qu'après A3 le fou des 4 n'aura plus de
case donc après tout c'est vite ramener
j'aurais simplement fou B3 ou B3 au
choix comme il le veut et là on ne sait
plus ce que j'aurai kaspard en fait les
blancs peuvent aussi
continuer à mettre la pression dans le
camp noir simplement par petit coup en
disant ben de toute façon tu auras du
mal à augmenter la qualité de tes pièces
alors que moi je vais augmenter leur
placement non mais le prochain coup de
cramique ça va être 1 2 3 de toute façon
toutes ces vitres voilà cramique va
mettre le fond en B3 c'est très probable
on s'est mis à deux à trois ah oui non
faut d'abord attention évidemment menace
de Kasparov tout de suite la tour
attaque le fou il faut que cramique
défende ce fou on peut envisager
peut-être dans deux c'est possible non
c'est pas bien il faut pour l'instant
on va voir tout de suite la variante si
les Blancs jouent d'un E2
pour défendre le fou la dame défend le
fou et bien tout de suite les Noirs
répondraient pas en cavalier et
puis la dame ne peut pas prendre
puisqu'il faut continuer à défendre le
fou donc il faudrait prendre du pion et
ça c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe puisque le roi blanc n'est
plus du tout pour TG et encore si on
fait une analyse de la des fameuse îlots
de pions on voit que les blancs en 4
îlots de pions ah c'est une horreur ce
qui est un maximum là c'est des pions
complètement isolés de tous les côtés
facile à attaquer
les uns les autres ça crée plein de
trous dans la position blanche c'est pas
possible il ne jouera pas simple
donne ce peut-être même qu'il n'y pense
même pas c'est sûr il va jouer vachement
fou B3 c'est le coup normal fou B3 ici
Stéphane alors chronique va probablement
jouer maintenant le fou ici sur la case
B3
ça c'est une possibilité donc évidemment
c'est à suivre le coup à deux à trois
suivis de dame 2 ça c'est des coups tout
à fait envisageable 1 2 3 on va montrer
c'est le petit pion ici qui attaquerait
1 à 3 le fou en B4 ça pose la question
au four ça peut te dire au fou qu'est-ce
que tu fais tu prends le cavalier ou tu
t'en vas au moins de décide-toi moi je
te pose la question cramique qui fait
ses pauses il se met bien à fond dans sa
chaise Vladimir chronique là il est
détendu alors là la question c'est qui
est le mieux préparé parce qu'il
semblerait que les deux joueurs soient
très bien préparés puisqu'ils ont
utilisé très peu de temps 15 minutes
pour casperoff et 10 pour cramique c'est
pas beaucoup là depuis quasiment les
trois dernières parties et bien les
joueurs récitent récitent quasiment ce
qui savent
là en fait les joueurs connaissent
toujours les plans possibles ici
simplement ils essaient de trouver celui
qui leur convient le mieux aujourd'hui
et qui peut poser le plus de problèmes à
leur adversaire en fonction de la
préparation qui leur suppose alors
disons Stephen que c'est une position
qui est par définition équilibrée c'est
à dire que chacun a ses chances c'est
pas une position qui promet un avantage
au blanc particulier simplement c'est
une position jouable à mon avis c'est ça
qu'on cherche Vladimir cramé qui cherche
à jouer aux échecs avant tout il veut
pas exploser castor off dans l'ouverture
puisque effectivement a priori c'est pas
possible
il a démontré plusieurs fois
qu'il est oui alors qu'on voit très bien
le superbe logo canal web derrière le
dos de cramique et oui c'est important
peut-être dans les mains ou même sur la
tête c'est pas clair il faudrait le
décider alors que nous avons changé de
réalisation je crois Stéphane oui tout à
fait je crois que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est Hélène
mais elle est aussi Corse donc pas de
souci pas de souci si l'arbitre vient
nous embêter et bien Hélène sera le
recevoir je crois qu'ici nous sommes
blindés maintenant d'ailleurs des
rideaux ont été posés oui alors c'est
non mais alors après la porte blindée
qui nous ont mis très vite pour protéger
la loge de Kasparov de la réalisation
oui et bien ils ont mis des rideaux
maintenant côté commentaire pour
protéger Garric à sport des
commentateurs
donc maintenant il est camouflé il est
calfeutrés non mais c'est un Castoral
des d'ores et déjà de trouver des
excuses à la perte du match et donc il
pourra expliquer que c'est la faute des
commentateurs
une possibilité possible en tout cas
Garric pour l'instant il fait pas trop
le mariage et nous à la réalisation nous
avons Hélène de Bastia qui assure
et voilà ramenez réfléchit on voit sur
ce très bon plan
de Marmande à la mafia c'est la mafia
lot-et-garonneaise et pas mal aussi
qui fait le trafic du foie gras je
rappelle que c'est un trafic très
courant dans la région c'est pas Laurent
Freyssinet qui est l'ordinaire de foie
gras
faucinet qui fait des pommes c'est
surtout les pommes
est un maître international français
c'est un des grands espoirs français
d'ailleurs avec Étienne Macron mais tout
à fait
18 ans 18 ans mettre international il a
été vision du monde cadet et d'ailleurs
il nous regarde actuellement en direct
c'est très probable très probable le
petit Laurent qui va bientôt partir aux
Olympiades pour représenter l'équipe de
France les Olympiades je crois Stéphane
ça commence dans trois ou quatre jours
oui et c'est à Istanbul donc l'équipe de
France est très belle cette année
puisque il y a que des jeunes et c'est
une équipe assez soudée je crois il y a
donc si on peut rappeler qui joue dans
l'équipe ouais donc il y a Laurent
Freyssinet
pas d'avis de marceno il y a Jean-Marc
Degrave Arnaud Hochard manuel Apicella
et encore un je ne sais plus lequel je
sais pas en tout cas il y aura ni
l'autre ni Macron ni Nataf puisqu'ils
en français ne sont pas là mais en tout
cas on aura une équipe très jeune alors
pourquoi là parce que le championnat du
monde
va commencer le vrai
donc à New Delhi championnat du monde de
la Fédération internationale lottier lui
va pas simplement parce qu'il est
secondant de cramique ici et ça c'est on
peut pas être partout à la fois
effectivement jouer l'outil numéro 1
français et le second dent de Vladimir
chronique donc il aide à la préparer ses
variantes contre kasparoff il faut
rappeler que Joël Lautier et le seul
joueur au monde à être positif contre
Kasparov avec cramique maintenant avec
Rami
alors ça c'est des statistiques depuis
que Castor fait devenu champion du monde
bien sûr puisque si on prend le
professeur de kasporov qui a dû le
battre quand il avait entre 5 et 8 ans
et bien ce n'est pas significatif en
revanche depuis 4h fait le champion du
monde il y a que deux joueurs sur Terre
à avoir un score dit positif
c'est-à-dire plus de victoire que de
défaite c'est Joël Lautier et
caricasporama
qui lui a gagné quatre fois et a perdu
trois parties mais depuis pas longtemps
alors mes chroniques donc pour l'instant
cramique démontre
qu'il est largement au niveau de
gasparov pour l'instant dans ce match et
même au dessus
pour l'instant l'étang de réflexion et
bien cramique est en train de rattraperf
ils vont bientôt avoir réfléchi un quart
d'heure chacun ouais c'est très peu ça
veut rien dire ça veut tout dire à rien
dire en fait c'est fans simplement dire
que les joueurs sont a priori encore
préparés et qui ne s'y attendait pas
forcément voilà on peut peut-être
traduire ça comme ça c'est-à-dire qu'ils
savent ce qu'il faut faire mais ils
veulent d'abord bien se rappeler bien
vérifier bien être sûr de ce qui va se
passer la partie bien bien se remémorer
tous les schémas peut-être que là c'est
le moment du plan pour Vladimir cramé
qu'on peut mentionner parce qu'il y a
deux cases pour le fou si on peut passer
sur l'échiquier des monstres qui est
attaqué le voilà il peut aller soit en
B3 il peut aller pas attaquer par la
tour ici on va montrer voilà on peut
aller soit sur la case B3 ici cette case
là soit à ce moment-là ça sera un jeu
long terme éventuellement accès un petit
peu vers le roi noir mais pas trop
plutôt accès vers la poussée des quatre
dessins puisque ce fou en B3 soutiendra
la poussée des cadres 5 on doit pousser
soutenir le pion qui avance ici
puisqu'en B3 il continue de protéger
cette case ça c'est un premier plan le
deuxième plan évidemment Stéphane c'est
de mettre le fou sur la case D3 deuxième
plan
c'est de mettre ce fou ici sur la case
D3 et ensuite de jouer de passer la tour
en fin d'essayer d'attaquer vers le pion
H7 c'est les deux plans cramique
évidemment connaît tout ça il y a pas
trop tard donc par E3 et ensuite H3
quand on aura bougé le cavalier pour
pilonner ce pion ici et attaquer le roi
ça c'est un plan un peu long ça va être
difficile à mettre en place mais c'est
un plan c'est un plan possible en tout
cas pas mal de possibilités mais je
pense que très logiquement cramique va
mettre son fou sur la caisse B3 ça
paraît quand même plus normal plus
logique ça parle plus décisif surtout
alors à noter quand même moi je vais
noter quelque chose dans la position
qu'il faut pas faire
on va noter un truc dans la position
c'est que le cavalier ici en 17 et bien
pour l'instant il est dominé puisque il
peut pas bouger vers le centre à cause
du pion en D4
il est bouché sur le cavalier sur FC il
peut pas bouger ce cavalier oui mais
c'est évidemment le gros inconvénient
d'avoir joué de cette formation avec B6
et 7 normalement avec un pion isolé on
hésite à mettre le foulard pourquoi déjà
un parce que ça avance le pion B on a
déjà dit lors de la 4e
et le deuxième évidemment le revers de
la médaille c'est que ça le pion est en
B6 il empêche la dame de sortir il
l'empêche lequel est de sortir ce pion
ici bouche les Noirs ce pion B6 ici la
dame le cavalier de bouger et évidemment
le gros avantage c'est que on voit que
les Noirs ont quand même réussi à sortir
toute leur pièce tout de suite et ça
c'est pas mal
donc problème de d'espace pour les Noirs
problème de mobilité on va dire il faut
que les Blancs continuent à augmenter
leur leur contrôle général des cases
pour empêtrer les Noirs dans la dans la
mélasse comme on dit je crois quand même
que chronique va mettre le fou sur la
caisse B3 c'est vraiment la case logique
celui de Dôme des trois fous ces deux
c'est un plan qui arrive alors on va
montrer ce plan tout simplement je vais
enlever
les quelques flèches qui nous gênent non
non on va le faire doucement on n'est
pas pressé
alors donc là on n'a pas joué tout de
suite alors là un autre plan possible on
va expliquer c'est qu'on jouerait le fou
ici
sur la case B3 et ensuite on joue la
dame ici ici
puis le fou on le ramènera ici sur la
casse C2 et on va voir que fou et dame
viseraient le pion H7 se crée une
batterie une batterie foudam ça ça
serait aussi qui potentiellement fort
qui pilote le roi noir voilà un plan
aussi un plan d'attaque
on peut peut-être Stéphane demander à
Théo ce qu'il pense de cette position
puisque il est avec nous dans la cabine
de commentaires
alors peut-être un petit mot sur ce
match qu'est-ce qu'on dit c'est OK de
Marseille
de revenir comme ça en B2 et 3 sur le 6
ça me paraît
merci merci Théo pour ce commentaire
lumineux et donc effectivement c'est le
match castford Cornic commenté
pour CanalWeb sur le site de one Games
également pour la version anglaise
malheureusement Théo n'est pas sur la
version anglaise mais ce n'est pas grave
puisqu'il y a nagelshort ancien candidat
contre Gary Kasparov qui fait et qui
fait quand même son effet sur les
commentaires anglais
je short qui a battu notre petit Bacro
champion de France double champion de
France par un petit score sévère
malheureusement trop un
trois victoires à une 4 2 je crois que
deux parties nuls ouais oui bah oui mais
bon
il joue quand même contre un gros
calibre un short c'est pas n'importe qui
vient de remettre du monde bon weekend
Macron Stéphane là ils sont encore en
train de réfléchir là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait viens on va
chercher des barres chocolatées
de la même position dimanche
c'est-à-dire que les joueurs ont recité
12 coups ah ça y est il va jouer du MP3
alors ça dame B3
on s'attendait en retrait du fou mais
non chronique attaque le fou B4 et
augmente le contrôle sur la case des 5
il veut jouer des 5 assez vite chronique
oui il veut jouer des seins qui veut
peut-être éventuellement
ont toujours le problème avec leur Dame
des hein alors que on vient nous
voir pour un petit commentaire Express
que se passe-t-il il y a une main qui
déborde
il s'agit de Yannick
par la technique alors voilà donc là
c'est encore une fois la magie du web il
faut à la fois commenter
et réaliser l'informatique c'est beau
voilà donc là
petit appel des lois au niveau de la
technique bon alors la casse pas en va
réfléchir évidemment longuement
probablement à ce coup c'est un
relativement surprenant
voire même très surprenant en fait c'est
très surprenant
alors là est-ce que les noirs
que peuvent jouer les Noirs ils peuvent
prendre éventuellement le cavalier en C3
et dans ce cas là il faudrait reprendre
de la tour
alors je vais
pouvoir manipuler l'ordinateur alors là
donc le problème pour les blancs après
ce coup c'est que le foot B7 pourrait
prendre le cavalier ici
voilà c'est un peu montrer les
démonstration parce que c'est possible
voilà donc le fou baisser pour reprendre
le cavalier et dans ce cas-là les Blancs
seront obligés de prendre du pion on a
dit que c'était pas bon puisque ça
détruit la défense du roi blanc mais
mais alors si le fou ici prend le
cavalier mais tout simplement la dame
reprend le fou en B4
voilà donc ça on prendrait pas le fou en
F3 mais le fou Mb4 et si les Noirs
prennent d'abord
je vais enlever les flèches ici
si les Noirs font d'abord en
cavalier et bien tout simplement on
reprend de la tour
et maintenant si il est noir prennent le
cavalier F3 et bien on reprend de la
tour et on n'a pas touché au pion voilà
ça c'est ce qu'il faut faire
alors rebonjour et bien on nous prévient
d'une chute de serveur Stéphane mais ce
n'est pas grave puisque ce n'est que
pour quelques minutes et donc pour
l'instant le tout continue à fonctionner
la vidéo marche très bien
côté côté canal web mais ce n'est pas
grave puisque ça ne va durer que
quelques minutes juste petit problème
pour la planète les coûts seront en
retard et pour l'instant la position que
vous avez ne tient pas compte mais la
vidéo continue la vidéo continue bien
sûr fonctionner mais qu'est-ce qu'elle
c'est quoi cette étude de serveur et
bien c'est comme une chute de cheveux il
y en a que quelques uns qui tombent et
en l'occurrence c'est les cheveux de la
plate qui sont tombés donc on a encore
explosé marche très bien on a encore
explosé le score quoi d'accord il se
posait le score
ça devient fatigant et bien je crois que
oui on va avoir un coup de fil du
président de canal qui va nous dire
d'arrêter ce match et de rentrer à la
maison car il y a trop de monde
il y a trop de monde et ça coûte trop
cher
qui ne tiennent pas le choc c'est
horrible c'est obligé d'arrêter pour
raison de succès trop important ça
arrive ça arrive il y a eu des
d'ailleurs il y a eu des il y a des
exemples comme ça loi de oui oui tout à
fait parce que ça marche trop bien c'est
clair c'est-à-dire que quand tout le
monde veut des Esquimaux et que il y a
plus d'esquimaux et bien on ne peut plus
chez Miko parce que Nico ne fournit pas
assez d'esquimaux
tout simple voilà qui a pu arriver et
après on est donc allé ailleurs par
exemple chez Ben et Jerry's ou chez
häagen Dats pour aller prendre des
Esquimaux quand on ne peut plus fournir
et bien on est dans la boîte tout
simplement heureusement avec un canal
web nous pouvons fournir de la vidéo
puisque la vidéo continue à marcher
simplement on prévient un petit décalage
au niveau de la plate ce n'est pas grave
ce n'est que quelques coups en fait
juste le coup MP3 n'a pas été pris en
compte donc voilà pas de problème donc
pas de gros problèmes petit problème de
serveur mais ça va être réglé il y a au
moins 10 personnes alors sur le coup à
kanaweb c'est sûr mentionne le coup
intéressant à 7 à 5 rappelons quand même
prendre un petit ordinateur
la position la solution se prend la tête
voilà l'ordinateur recommande ce coup à
cette A5 qui est tout à fait bizarre
puisqu'il a fait pipi effectivement il
n'est plus défendu comme ça et ça c'est
ennuyeux puisque ça donne aussi la casse
B5 au blanc bref c'est un coup qui a
énormément de d'inconvénients sans avoir
aucun avantage mais d'appareil photo
vraisemblablement le coup dans cette
position c'est de ramener le fou sur la
case au 7 qui est très très logique mais
peut aussi prendre le Cavaillon C3 mais
ça donne la paire de fou ouais tout à
fait prononcer trois semaines alors là
on voit ce problème avec la dame de
cette toujours qui peut pas bouger et si
on prend le cavalier et bien ça sera la
fameuse thématique Stéphane on rappelle
que cramenic a trouvé la méthode spa off
oui je prends la paire de fou j'ai
changé
il a trouvé le truc c'est facile de
jouer pour chronique c'est toujours
pareil je prends la paire de fou
j'échange les dames et je pilonne B3 ou
B6 et après je gagne tranquillement in
the noise
fingers in the noise une zone in the
nose plutôt Stéphane sinon c'est pas bon
alors que Théo a un petit coup de petit
coup de fatigue
c'est pas la télé
c'est pas la télé du foot c'est la télé
des échecs et c'est plus petit c'est que
les locaux sont plus petits puisque un
terrain de foot je vous rappelle mesure
170 m sur sur 70 quelque chose comme ça
on va peut-être mettre en gros plan
quand même pour montrer une fois de plus
le Titan de la planète échec l'ogre de
Bakou qui est en difficulté puisqu'ils
une petite petite ratée
sur l'échiquier on va toujours sa
fameuse pose bien en avant
comme d'habitude Yannick Wellen si vous
pouvez cadrer un peu plus à gauche
Stéphane il est il sait pas trop quoi
regarder là il casse pas il est encore
ses sourcils levés comme s'il était
battu il va peut-être encore se plaindre
je rappelle que kranik embête le petit
gari et que ça plaît pas la maman la
maman de Kasparov
qui est allé voir la maman de Granny qui
lui a dit votre fils embête le mien tout
à fait il veut pas le laisser jouer
mais enfin à noter quand même à trouver
des méthodes ah ça y est là il est
complètement tête dans les mains il y a
assommé tout simplement il est quand
même force Vladimir il arrive à
maintenir le King à distance il le tient
d'une main comme ça et Casper il est
plus grand combien il mesure que peut
mesurer à peu près 1 m 70 72 il est
petit alors que cramique lui fait
presque 2 mètres fait 1m96 donc il peut
le tenir à distance peut-être cramique
intimide casse-parents après la après le
match comme un peu tu sais les petits
après la récré on va faire après l'école
dise tu fais attention toi ou je te
casse la tête ouais d'accord ouais ouais
ouais non non mais bon comme dans la
chanson comme dans la chanson de
de notre ami comment il s'appelle
Souchon tarte ta gueule à la récré tarte
ta gueule
c'est possible il a peut-être peur
d'être ami
il a peut-être peur qu'elle se parle
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il arrive pas
à jouer depuis le début
déjà premier point écran nique à la
réputation d'être un joueur qui annule
beaucoup de parties mais castor off lui
gagne énormément de parties mécaniques
lui a trouvé des techniques pour pour
annuler facilement ça peut être qu'on
gagne pas c'est une question de style il
faut rappeler le champion du monde
petrociant par exemple dans les années
60 est un champion du monde qui faisait
nul souvent c'était son style il
préférait dans les positions risquées
mais souvent assurer la nul plutôt que
risquer des choses
une s'aventurer que quand il était sûr
de son coup mais alors là est-ce qu'on
peut ouais effectivement c'est le fameux
truc qui nous qui nous contrarie un peu
ça serait un champion du monde avec 15
minutes et un gains ouais mais pas plus
que petroscien qui avait été champion du
monde un peu de la même façon c'est
autre chose c'est un autre style quoi
c'est un style c'est le style muraille
c'est le style un peu muraille
je te laisse pas passer et je profite de
la moindre occasion la chronique a pris
un point ça y est
il va repousser casse-parents jusqu'au
bout en leur faisons un bilan position
on va référencer toutes les possibilités
que garantissent par off 1 là voilà ça y
est c'est l'heure des boutons de
manchette Stéphane ah ah il nous fait le
coup alors en général il arrive pas à
les remettre les boutons de sa chemise
il n'y arrive pas voilà bah ça y est là
il est en train de peiner alors
maintenant le deuxième voilà assez dur
c'est dur Gary mais tu vas y arriver il
a été beaucoup plus vite il est quand
même beaucoup plus entraîné qu'avant
maintenant avec ces boutons de chemise
puisqu'il arrive à les mettre très vite
voilà on a vu aussi qu'il a enlevé sa
montre comme d'habitude
je me rappelle qu'il met sa montre sur
le bord de l'échiquier je sais pas si on
pourra le voir dans un plan tout à
l'heure et à noter que aujourd'hui comme
il y a les noirs et bien il a mis un
gilet noir Stéphane quand il a du blanc
il neige oui effectivement les deux
joueurs ont un petit jeu de couleur au
niveau de la tenue vestimentaire et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
un
petit regard furtif de Garric
voilà la montre voilà la montre très
beau plan là sur la montre Castorama
alors il pose probablement la montre à
côté de l'échiquier pour ceux qui
viennent de découvrir aujourd'hui
à cause du temps il vérifie à ça avec sa
montre que la pendule
est bien à l'heure et qu'elle joue pas
trop vite ou trop lentement vous voyez
alors la vérité est tout autre Stéphane
puisque effectivement il est sponsorisé
par une marque de montre il faut pas le
dire il faut pas le dire d'accord mais
Gary castrov est quand même sponsorisé
quand même
ce qui explique pourquoi il enlève
systématiquement ça montre alors on va
faire un bilan position quand même
puisque c'est l'heure un petit peu de
voir les possibilités de dire à sport
donc si on peut mettre
l'échiquier de démonstration
voilà
le voilà merci à la Real et donc
directrice parfait le faut attaquer
plusieurs possibilités il peut mettre le
four à 5 c'est pas bon on peut prendre
le KFC 3 c'est pas beau le foin à 5 et
loin c'est pas beau mais il est en
délogeable et puis pour apprendre le
kfc4 pour menacer à tout moment fou au 7
c'est une autre possibilité il peut
aussi peut-être aller en D6 avec le fou
je ne sais pas
on a éliminé positionnellement la
possibilité
donc voilà toutes les possibilités
directement le coup attendu quand même
Stéphane je ne sais pas si c'est fou
aussi à tout fou ces trois mais
peut-être vous prend cavalier
prendre de la tour et ça active tout de
suite une tour c'est pas c'est pas
envisageable ça parce que les Blancs
menacent tout de suite cavaliers 5 et
court H3 probablement
enfin en tout cas ça active la tour
plusieurs
je pense pas non je pense qu'il va jouer
kosparov foot et six pourquoi pas c'est
le coup un peu inattendu c'est un peu
dans le style ça non parce que fou des 6
on pourrait jouer fou B8 dame C7 non
mais Stephen trois objectifs
c'est pas une très belle solution
puisque après qu'il y avait 5 on ne sait
plus quoi faire déjà on peut le
mentionner d'ailleurs sur fou D6 déjà
premier problème c'est qu'on n'utilise
plus du tout la colonne D les prochaines
et bien c'est que les blancs peuvent
bondir directement avec le coup fous ces
quatre champions aussi ah oui ça c'est
un problème assez grave je crois oui
c'est vrai et oui ça serait un sacrifice
terrible puisque les Noirs reprenant en
forêt dame prend pion avec échec
le roi bouge et on récupère le fou avec
deux champs plus
fou des 6 ne marche pas
exceptionnellement ne sera pas joué par
le directeur en revanche il va peut-être
jouer fou au 7
sur quoi il y a pas mal de possibilités
il faut aussi être on peut jouer avec le
5 a l'air bien c'est c'est possible
alors sympa donc là évidemment tout ce
que vous voyez sur cette échiquier ce
n'est pas la position réelle c'est bien
entendu les possibilités
il faut y penser quand il y a un pion
isolé à convertir la structure de pions
c'est à dire que là on a pris isolé
l'option est parti sur la caisse de 5 et
donc il y a plus de faiblesses de
structure là le cavalier B5 qui arrive
sur la caisse des 6 oui parce que le
pire on va expliquer pourquoi il voit
peut être protégé par le pion F2 peut
venir en F4 protéger ce pur donc il est
plus isolé il est plus isolé de son
paquet de pions amis voilà donc là ça
donne une position équilibrée notamment
mais comme les Noirs pas de faiblesse
il y a d'autres possibilités pour les
blancs il y a plein de possibilités la
position il y a plein de possibilités
en A5 bref pour l'instant on dirait va
jouer dans une optique de gain ou dans
une optique de nul
dans une optique de gamme possible bien
sûr même avec les Noirs
ça va pas oui
très peu d'opportunités donc c'est bien
pour communiquer il est mal casse pas
off il est mal dans ce match il faut
bien le faut bien le dire donc sur la
position il est pas mal mais il est mal
dans le match c'est
sûrprenant dans MP3 ça
lui c'est encore cramique qui pose des
problèmes à Casa c'est encore lui qui
sort Kasparov de des lignes les plus
pointues
oui les plus à la mode ouais on peut
dire ça bah c'est à dire que cramique
est là pour jouer la défense berlinoise
à chaque fois crani trouve des trucs oui
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut connait
probablement MP3 à mon avis mais il y a
pas en priorité pour aujourd'hui donc il
faut qu'il se rappelle
énormément d'intox dans ces réflexions
de d'ouverture c'est pas parce que le
Castorama pour l'instant réfléchit une
demi-heure qu'il est complètement hors
répertoire non il est pas en répertoire
mais disons qu'il y a sûrement préparé
pour la partie d'aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui est différent de plus frais
joue un joueur comme ça qui refuse le
débat théorique parce que même carpov
accepter le débat théoriques
pour trouver des améliorations rejouer
les mêmes variantes etc lucrannique non
cramique dévier assez vite ouais c'est
vrai chronique l'empêche chronique
glisse chronique saute dans le champ de
maïs et ne permet pas à castor de le
viser à noter Stéphane que c'est quand
même pas du tout la même formule carpov
est cramique puisque les matchs avec
airpov c'était à durée illimité en
premier match le premier et donc dans ce
genre de match il fallait jouer les
mêmes ouvertures essayez tout tout ce
qui était possible alors que là c'est un
match a duré courte 16 parties seulement
ça veut dire que si on commence à
s'enliser dans un débat théorique ça va
créer beaucoup de nuls et ça c'est plus
possible pour gagner Kasparov maintenant
est un peu obligé d'essayer de tout de
suite trouver quelque chose que ramener
n'a pas prévu
et gagner la dernière partie durant les
Noirs la dernière c'est lui il les avait
aussi mais chronique
en 87 contre carpov ou bénéfice du match
nul alors qu'il était mené à une partie
de la fin contre Karpov il était mené et
il a gagné la dernière partie à
l'arracher avec les Noirs c'est
incroyable ce qui était arrivé à ce
moment là
ça c'est du jamais vu ça s'est jamais
fait dans un championnat du monde
d'échec
comme ça que le champion
gagne la dernière partie pour garder ou
conserver son titre
donc réforme n'est jamais battue donc
tant qu'on sera pas la dernière partie
il y aura de l'espoir non
de retard avant
8 points et demi à n'importe quel moment
dans le match et bien fin du match tout
simplement mais il continue le match
mais bon ça sera plus pareil ça sera
plus pareil ça n'aura plus l'intérêt que
ça maintenant
c'est quand même garrix qui avait prévu
d'être champion du monde jusqu'en 2010
je crois on ne voyait pas qui pouvait
l'arrêter et maintenant il semblerait
que ce soit Vladimir cramé qui va le
stopper
il va le stopper net Stéphane est-ce
qu'on peut peut-être se dresser un bilan
des joueurs qui peuvent poser des
problèmes à Gary castor off dans le top
10 mondial chronique ça c'est sûr il y a
aussi Peter l'écho effectivement le
jeune Hongrois et même un endroit qui
lui pose des problèmes il n'arrive il a
du mal à gagner contre Peter Lego
castorroffre
très technique on va le rappeler à
gagner le Grand Prix de Bordeaux
contre qui c'était d'ailleurs et bien
c'était contre un fort joueur puisqu'il
s'agissait d'Alex Alicia
évidemment ce Grand Prix de Bordeaux
vous pouvez le retrouver dans les
différé de diagonales puisque c'est la
magie de la télé sur Internet c'est un
dimanche Stéphane c'est quand on veut
c'est à la carte voilà c'est à la carte
et puis on est pas obligé d'être là en
direct on peut attendre le lendemain ou
plus tard
alors sauf pour ce championnat du monde
parce que c'est trop long là 6 heures de
direct
c'est pas enregistré tous les jours
simplement le résumé quand même c'est
bien résumé les meilleurs moments de ces
commentaires live et également la
conférence de presse voilà il y a quand
même tous les moments pour revivre le
match le lendemain alors Stephen
qu'est-ce qui s'est dit par exemple à la
conférence de presse de la dernière
partie
parce que même pas dire c'était dimanche
oui donc c'était la partie
alors cramique donc avec les Noirs
dans cette conférence de presse c'est
casprof qui dit j'aurais 80% de chance
de gagner si dans la 7e partie j'avais
joué autre chose que tourner deux c'est
la fameuse partie bref et chronique le
dit non non non
puisque effectivement c'est complètement
égal dans tous les cas vous pouvez
consulter mes analyses sur Internet bref
chronique la proprement donc il y a eu
un petit un petit accrochage entre
castorfé cramique à la conférence de
presse qui est donc écrit effectivement
est archivée vous pouvez la revoir
ça c'est effectivement l'intérêt de la
télé sur Internet
qui se laisse pas impressionner
là il est embêté c'est sûr alors autant
et bien comment ça prend un peu de
retard que c'est pas off puisqu'il va
réfléchir depuis bientôt 46 minutes on
part dans 36 minutes
contre 29
on en est au 13e coup je vous rappelle
que les joueurs en deux heures pour
jouer 40 coups donc pour l'instant les
joueurs sont bien dans la moyenne
pas de problème à peu près toujours 3
minutes il en reste à peu près en
moyenne 3 minutes par coup
ce qui est normal un petit peu moins non
pour y aller c'est un petit peu moins un
truc
et dans la norme à noter que bon il faut
pas vraiment réfléchir comme ça Stéphane
les 10 premiers coups les joues en moins
de 10 minutes alors qu'après il commence
à réfléchir donc en fait il y a 30 coups
pour une heure 50 à peu près
puisque effectivement c'est très
difficile de surprendre deux joueurs de
ce niveau dans l'ouverture ah il y a un
cas sport la pause qu'elle pose là
Stéphane là c'est la pose du doigt la
pose du doigt le doigt posé sur l'oeil
un petit peu comme si on a un plan sur
les doigts voilà on voit très bien
manucure et
je sais pas si c'est important à noter
mais
Stéphane je ne sais pas non plus
peut-être que ça plaira à certaines
télés
port of a quand même beaucoup de charme
ça c'est ton avis je te le laisse tu le
partage
je me suis mis
pour l'instant un organisant ce match ah
oui il faut savoir quand même que c'est
à l'initiative de Kia sport que le match
a été organisé
ça lui plaît pas sa position ne lui
plaît pas trop non il fait un nom de la
tête non c'est pas possible il connaît
forcément ce coup de MP3 mais il se dit
je suis tombé dans un truc à la cramique
c'est ça pas c'est ça qui se dit alors
je ne sais pas ce qu'il se dit
exactement ce moment c'est assez
difficile à savoir à mon avis il est
plutôt en train de se rappeler quand il
avait analysé cette position avec yoshif
Dorfman en 81 et donc il y a une
vingtaine d'années quand ils avaient
trouvé plein d'idées intéressantes pour
les Noirs il est en train de
restructurer toutes les variantes qu'il
avait qu'il avait regardé pour cette
position il y a 20 ans
fait tellement gigantesque même si
c'était fait il y a 20 ans ils s'en
rappellent encore et donc bon enfin avec
un peu moins d'acuité évidemment que si
c'était hier pas mal surtout de
retrouver tout ça donc là les caricas
Paros est en train d'essayer de se
rappeler ce qu'il le connaît sur cette
position mais pour l'instant apparemment
il ne trouve pas de chemin qui lui
plaisent
on est loin on est loin encore d'avoir
atteint le moment décisif de cette
partie mais mais 15 par off là encore il
fait sa tête encore une fois des mauvais
jours
on n'a pas souvent vu dans ce match la
tête des beaux jours Stéphane puisque
castorrov est dominé tout le temps et
voilà ça y est là il est complètement il
est complètement anesthésié le pauvre
castor off il a fait une mine
complètement des confites non non mais
il est pas bien il gagne sport il est il
sait plus comment faire contre cramique
là il sait plus il sait plus où il
habite garrix
alors bon mais pourtant c'est toujours
l'ouverture il y a pas grand chose à
dire c'est un choix
on va dire c'est un choix c'est même pas
un choix stratégique il doit faire 80
choix personnel
oui
en fait il cherche à jouer les coups non
je pense que c'est plus compliqué que ça
quand même à mon avis là il y a pas
beaucoup de coups qui sont bons là oui
non mais bon c'est pas vraiment une
question de goût c'est vraiment une
question d'objectivité parce que
cramique si on lui donne non mais
n'oublions pas que dans toutes les
parties qu'on a vu chaque fois
qu'il y avait un mini avantage un micro
avantage ça a été transformé quand même
ça c'est vrai il faut quand même le
freiner
je vais sacrifier un pion
quand je veux toute façon quand je veux
puisque semble-t-il il y a beaucoup de
mal oui alors il y a quand même quelque
chose qu'on a pas envisagé Stéphane qui
est pas négligeable c'est le coup pour
l'instant oui mais quatre heures donc
avant tu ne reviennes on va voir on va
voir le le on va revoir ça c'est
intéressant sur le site de démonstration
voilà surtout prends F3 c'est
intéressant parce que les Blancs ne
peuvent pas reprendre du pion le fou
sinon ça détruit le rempart du roi blanc
ça ça détruit la structure de des pions
qui défendent le roi donc il faudrait
reprendre le fou en B4 voilà tout
simplement le four reviendrait à l'heure
en B7 et blanc on la paire de fou les
Blancs ont pris la paire de fou d'un
autre côté on leur a éliminé alors
qu'elle va froid qui était une belle
pièce Stéphane puisqu'il permettait
d'aller loin on peut jouer même dessin
que l'air terrible qui a l'air terrible
qu'est-ce qu'on fait terrible terrible
on va avoir la paire de fou j'ai
l'impression
nous informe d'un coup intéressant
Stéphane
c'est vrai donc on ferait pas peut-être
pas des cinq tours
mais je ne sais pas peut-être que
castorph mon visage quand même cette
position il faut pas la faut pas la
négliger
à 7 ici on joue qu'est-ce qu'on joue
ouais ça ressemble à un geste technique
des B5 c'est pas mal puisqu'on vise
aussi la case D6 attaquant le faux B7 ça
a l'air embêtant c'est clair ce n'est
pas acceptable attaquant la tour C8
voilà la position
ça a pas l'air très bon
voilà alors que Théo va probablement
nous quitter pour l'instant
ce qui va changer de cassette et filmer
un peu la régie il va filmer Yannick
Yannick si tu es là et Hélène
prépare-toi probablement un peu
voilà donc là ici
là c'est chaud
alors
ici
passe
en réflexion
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que je joue
c'est ça que je vous demande quel sport
fou à 5
ouais x 5
fous des 6 qui a pas l'air bon
il se rapproche de l'heure 17 minutes il
nous reste pour rapprocher l'heure et on
rappelle que si il dépasse l'heure avant
le 20e coup et bien et on peut supposer
qu'il va être transitent
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle alors c'est
quoi ce que c'est pour les gens qui nous
rejoignent aujourd'hui parce que vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à chaque
fois on s'arrête pas de grandir on se
demande jusqu'où ça va aller
et oui alors vous êtes note et loi ça va
être note ça vient de l'allemand qui
veut dire crise de temps si je ne fais
pas d'erreur et donc crise de temps ça
veut dire que effectivement comme il
faut jouer 40 coups en moins de deux
heures si on a joué 10 coups et qu'on a
réfléchi
1h50 et bien il reste 30 coups à jouer
en 10 minutes et là ça commence à être
chaud puisqu'il faut les débiter les
coûts Stéphane c'est pas toujours facile
oui parce que si on dépasse le temps et
qu'on n'a pas atteint le 40ème coup et
bien on perd la partie tout simplement
on perd la partie sur tapis vert ça
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est pas
tapis vert on perd autant réfléchit on a
peut-être joué des bons coups mais
l'adversaire a joué des coups au moins
aussi bon et en beaucoup moins de temps
même si on a une position gagnante et
bien on perd quand même on dirait une
note ça c'est une possibilité qu'il faut
pas négliger c'est à noter c'est
fondamental le temps aux échecs
on a senti cramique un peu en difficulté
c'est quand il était dominé autant
il trouve des solutions
crânique a presque une demi-heure
d'avance autant et les seules
imprécisions que comme écran Nick c'est
quand il est lui-même en crise de temps
mais pour cette partie ça a l'air un peu
raté mais est-ce que ça ne dormirait pas
à force de plonger dans cette position
moi ça m'arrive dans les tournois enfin
ça m'est arrivé quand je joue des
tournois je joue plus beaucoup
mais effectivement quand on réfléchit on
réfléchit on réfléchi on finit par
s'endormir et même voir des fantômes de
temps voir des fantômes des choses qui
n'existent pas et puis
finalement on est obligé de tout
recommencer au bout d'un moment de tout
reculé parce que finalement c'est plus
qu'on ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vu oui mais
à mon avis casse pas offs un algorithme
de calcul un peu plus évolué un peu plus
travaillé avec le tien ce qui lui permet
donc de ne pas tourner à vide après il
fait il fait quand même la gueule il a
pas l'air la gueule
oui c'est vrai
et puis on se demande bien pourquoi
parce que ça a l'air de faire ses
grimaces mais quand même toujours qu'au
13e coup de MP3 est un coup encore
envisagé dans cette position connue
sûrement madame B3 ouais sans doute déjà
été joué c'est très probable
jusqu'à quelqu’un démontre que c'est
mauvais coup à noter quand même que
après n'importe quel retrait du Fou
défense du Fou le cavalier 3 fois en
prise donc vraisemblablement enfin en
prise façon de parler puisque sur
fulpron on sera obligé de reprendre du
pion donc ranix sera obligé de réagir
surtout au 7 il faudra qu'il joue soit
tout droit soit cavalier 5 au choix
ou cavalier B5 et peut-être qu'elle est
B5 je ne crois qu'à aller au 2
pour venir en G3
ici
dans cette position 2 on ne veut
absolument pas laisser garer pendant F3
c'est sur mon sac se dit caricat de
force c'est pour ça que MP3 est un peu
surprenant puisque ça laisse cette
menace en l'air
donc ici on envisage cavalier au 5
qu'est-ce qu'on peut envisager d'autre
la machine recommande fulprince mais ça
a l'air non faut complètement aberrant
il faut regarder ici ce qui se passe il
y a un problème tactique quel problème
après faut prendre cette on est très
ennuyé puisque si on prend du cavalier
il y a tourdéen je crois ouais
ça m'a l'air plus subtil ça menace de
une pièce c'est quand même un pion si on
prend on joue alors il faudrait jouer
non mais Adam dames C7 là peut-être même
C7 ce serait chaud non c'est chaud non
mais c'est clair que la position a quand
même des choses il y a des choses
tactiques à trouver peut-être
bon
il y a des complications tactiques à
venir à noter qu'après vous êtes
évidemment et bien cramique ne veut pas
jouer cavalier 5 il peut toujours jouer
un coup comme tout droit qui a pas l'air
terrible cela dit non moi et en plus
j'ai 4
ça changera des pièces
il faut pas changer de pièce
avec un pion isolé gardez les pièces sur
les chutier donc pourquoi Garric
fait-elle cette fétine
est-ce qu'on peut pas envisager il faut
prendre aussi sinon jamais puis on prend
d'en prendre un chèque il faut jouer il
faut que je tournef 7
il faut jouer au F7 et là
pour le jouer il a joué la partie la
position que vous avez devant les yeux
voilà je crois que les démonstrations
cramique mais la pression
regardez
on le sent moins stressé
alors que cramique Miss c'est le calme
et la sérénité
ici il a les blancs il est tranquille
contre Gary kaspor il mène le match il
est très très relax
ça me match en cette partie le score
pour l'instant c'est 5 à 4
granny
en costard
faut dire que les joueurs ont les moyens
il y a 2 millions de dollars de prix
dont deux tiers gagnants un tiers en
perdant
donc ils peuvent acheter des costards
alors là
faut prendre aussi
qui gagne une pièce non
pour l'instant je suis un petit problème
de micro mais ça va être résolu dans
quelques instants je suis en train de le
démanteler
ce type de c'est pas ça peut pas
ouais c'est peut-être une nouveauté
théorique non je crois pas non
personne n'y croit
en tout cas j'y crois pas
prends
je calcule quand même un peu parce que
je sais pas pourquoi mais ça me tarde se
aussi
ouais mais j'ai pas on sait jamais
quelque chose ou en trouver quelque
chose pour maintenir les noces sous
pression parce que quand même la Tour
Eiffel c'est hyper mal placé on va pas
trop comment
non
c'est curieux
stupéfiant complètement non ça
ressemblerait inattendu et incroyable à
la fois l'idée de ce coup Stéphane sur
quel profil et oui et oui enfin pourquoi
ça marche ah oui
donc il faut faire il faut et alors va
jouer tempo Stéphane on le sent et là il
y a des scènes
qui est possible d'attaque le pion à 7
et va sur la case des 6 bref
cette impressionnant il ne faudra sur
cavalier prend F6 et bien là c'est
l'heure c'est le matin
avec échec il faut que je t'aurais fait
pour éviter de perdre le fou t'attaquer
par la dame et surtout et le fouet est
en prise par la dame et la tour voilà 7
et là et là bon cavalier en G5
attaque la Tour Eiffel et les Noirs les
Blancs récupèrent tout tout le matos
et après on prend le fou enfin c'est
horrible donc nous revenons sur la
position c'est horrible donc il faut pas
jouer qui avait pris un fils mais il
faut prendre
ah pas clair puis on prend si on profite
sur D5 c'est une horreur
la structure de pion et une attaque sur
le Renoir deviendrait terrible c'est
vrai il faut prendre du fou mais là il
faut quand même se demander Stéphane
ceux qui se passe après cavalier Besson
non ça a l'air bidon ça a l'air
complètement bidon
à 8 Stéphane c'est une sorte de
capitulation toi
parce que la tour était très bien placé
en C8 on perd deux temps pour la
remettre sur la case à 8
et là il y a des belles perspectives
pour cramique qui peut envisager le coup
de dessin maintenant
tranquillement ou alors mettre une tour
en D1 la dame de kaspora n'a toujours
pas trop de cases je sais pas peut-être
bonne fin de toute façon si cramique a
joué il a ses raisons il joue assez vite
et Kasparov réfléchit et réfléchis il
réfléchit à quoi cramique a-t-il pensé
en jouant cette position waouh puis on
prend fou un homme significata fait
comprendre c'est horrible donc voilà la
position actuelle c'est celle-là pour la
première star
et puis on prend fou D5 avec une très
grosse attaque
des 5 ça fait mal très gros attaque
c'est marrant ça est obligé est-ce qu'on
peut supposer que cramique bon enfin on
suppose évidemment que ramener puisqu'il
a joué au profit très vite alors que
normalement il faut pointer c'est quand
même une faute positionnelle parce que
ça donne la paire de fou ça donne la
paire de fou hein
pour une fois chronique ne prend pas la
paire de fou il la donne
à noter qu'on arrive dans une position
qui se simplifie Stéphane
puisque c'est un échange de pièces
tendance à simplifier
et proposer nul voilà donc on va bientôt
on va attendre la partie le jeudi moi
bien d'ailleurs s'il fait nul c'est pas
forcément une mauvaise nouvelle puisque
je crois qu'elle a la télé ce soir il y
a un super film
non non mais on espère on espère qu'il y
aura pas de
on espère rater le film quand même on
espère quand même va-t-il faire
effectivement ça non mais on va voir ce
que
est-ce que crânik va se contenter de
faire nul
et de frustrer tout le monde
c'est possible
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas après
tout point 6 c'est autrement plus
compliqué que ça Stéphane puisqu’un
déséquilibre énorme sur l'échiquier il y
a un pion isolé la paire de fou ça
commence à faire beaucoup
ça oblige les Noirs à rendre la paire de
fou et on obtient une partie qui va être
nulle ah non je vois pas des seins qui
jouera c'est sûr
ouais mais ça laisse la casse des cinq
non moi après faut point 6 bon on peut
on peut jeter de démonstration pour
montrer quand même ce qui se passe
et que c'est à quoi il réfléchit parce
qu'il semblerait que ça soit forcé il
faut prendre un fils c'est forcé il
réfléchit peut-être entre fous points
pieds c'est je propose nul non
non c'était une plaisanterie bien sûr
donc c'est probable qu'il est encore
mieux aujourd'hui c'est à chaque fois
que je dis non sur une idée des lois
par rapport à une partie nulle proposée
par kasparoff et bien la nul ne tarde
pas à venir non mais ça serait ça serait
énervant non mais ça n'arrivera pas on
va montrer le chiquer démonstration
quand même pour montrer le problème des
noirs
de démonstration voilà voilà ici après 6
et bien qu'est-ce qui se passe la case
des 5 est bien des Noirs sont très loin
de la contrôler puisque le cahier des 7
ne peut plus venir sur la case fixe
Stéphane donc ici on risque plus de se
faire bloquer notre pion ça c'est un
premier argument le deuxième c'est qui
on joue qui a B5 ouais j'aime pas
qu'elle B5
ça force quasiment tout ravie et
maintenant pour envisager soit des 5
soit qui est des 6 qui a l'air pas mal
non plus ouais mais là on joue six non
alors je crois que sur fossais si je
jouais le cavalier 5 commence par poser
des serieux problèmes c'est vrai ah bah
oui puisque
il faut prendre
là ça rend la paire de fou F3 il y a des
coûts comme qui peuvent venir
ouais mais là attention pion isolé avec
moins de pièces c'est vrai c'est pas
forcément évident à noter que vous prend
des cartes c'est qu'il est pour un F7
avec complication
et autre possibilité après qu'il y avait
baissé un qui a tendance cette position
Stéphane il y a un coup qu'on a pas
mentionné mais qui est évidemment très
fort c'est le coup qui est vidéo 5 je
crois ouais à mon avis c'est menace pas
grand chose ça me fait cavalier pan
cavalier
alors là je crois que tu es en train de
mal tourner dans cette voiture
D1 dans la tête je crois que ici alors
si on compare bien la position des tours
par exemple c'est horrible c'est un
exemple assez horrible les blancs et les
Noirs ont de tours de merdes en fait ça
fait quand même quelque chose de venir
en B8 en V8
voilà il y a plein de gagne en ligne
c'est fini attendez 7 a l'air de gagner
en ligne donc là alors non évidemment on
fait pas comme cavalier ça c'était pour
montrer ce qu'il fallait pas faire alors
cavalier 5 c'est pas mal voilà donc là
il décide
toujours la thématique
il y a beaucoup de menaces là Stéphane
tout le temps ce qui est quand même
excellent c'est que vous pouvez M6
je ne sais pas Stéphane mais quand même
que le joue tempo et que se replonge
dans une réflexion dans une préparation
de granit avec les Blancs c'est possible
une préparation de chronique avec les
Blancs et loin oui mais c'est possible
parce qu'on a vu que la préparation avec
les Noirs ça faisait mal oui on peut pas
s'envoyer les blancs ça risque
d'affaires très mal bah la seule
préparation de chronique qu'on ait vu
avec les Blancs pour l'instant c'est la
partie qu'il a gagné la grenfeld qu'il a
proprement démonté la grandeur
in the box
il faut le dire
il est pas bien notre ami Gary fait un
nom de la tête casse pas
qu'est-ce qui a pu lui échapper à noter
que sur fou point F3 bien évidemment il
y a vous recettes avec un gain de pièces
intermédiaire
est-ce possible
ça serait quand même très surprenant
cette partie ça devient quand même très
très dur pour Castorama
tu vas être super chaude en tout
casserole va être super chaud c'est sûr
il va être il va sortir
le sort d'une sorte de triangle un truc
très solide ah ouais on ne passe pas
mais il peut également jouer la défense
minzovic je peux jouer ce qu'il veut
Vladimir cramique il est très à l'aise
mais là casse pas effectivement là
il a la pression casse-parents quand
même parce que si il fait nul le match
continue et c'est très chaud mais si il
perd il est quasiment ko ah oui presque
chaos c'est comme si il mettait le
deuxième genou à terre non mais là non
mais faut pas vu
je le crois pas
n'aurait pas vu ce coup faut prendre M6
tout simple
et qui pose de gros gros problèmes
semble-t-il
donc la faute ce serait peut-être pour
ces 8
peut-être vous êtes peut-être
la vie ici Gary
quoi que le problème du cavalier des 7
qui peut pas bouger c'est quand même en
mettant si on regarde le développement
Stéphane dans cette position qu'est-ce
qu'on voit et bien les blancs sont
largement en avance ils ont sorti toutes
leurs pièces alors que les Noirs ils ont
encore une dame et une tour en jeu à
quoi correspondance peut bien réfléchir
bah peut-être j'ai point F6 non mais
j'ai pris F6 c'est tout à fait affreux
c'est comme ça
on va expliquer encore une fois pourquoi
les lois le coup qu'a les principes ne
marche pas tout simplement il faut le
dire quand les principes et bien il y a
le cou fou prend pion aussi
énorme ce coup surprenant ça gagne un
pion il faut que les Noirs reprennent
alors oui puisque le problème évidemment
c'est que si on veut prendre en F3 avec
le fou et bien le fou aussi ce qui était
là et bien il disparaît il va prendre la
Tour Eiffel
qualité et un plus ça commence à être
beaucoup il faut donc prendre ce
fouet
c'est forcé puisqu'on a vu que sur toi 7
il y a un if5
si la tour s'interpose pour défendre le
foot
pour limiter la casse il faut donc je re
ensuite sur quoi bien entendu on
récupère la pièce avec deux pions de
plus et surtout pour F3
on joue je prends ah oui ça c'est
possible à jouer peut-être non non
peut-être que après faut prendre il faut
au préalable échanger les dames ah voilà
peut-être d'apprendre ouais non mais
c'est pareil si on prend des quatre il y
a pas de pions plus c'est loin alors
ouais mais bien de plus il est ridicule
c'est un doublé tours
bah voilà peut-être c'est ça que Castor
regarde il regarde peut-être cette
finale Stéphane pionpont
avec avantage blanc c'est clair c'est
peut-être une petite finale tranquille
alors peut-être que kaspora fait en
train de se dire est-ce que je peux
tenir dans cette finale voilà c'est ça
il a le choix à 4 mois en fait il peut
rentrer dans cette finale que la vie des
choses
pendant cette finale revenons un peu en
arrière si cette finale est nul Stéphane
je vois pas pourquoi il n'irait pas dans
cette finale non mais je suis pas dans
mes cramique il a pas joué pour ça pour
ça quand même
à moins qu'ils connaissent très très
bien cette finale parce que ça peut ça
peut être le cas aussi c'est peut-être
juste un peu avantageuse au blanc très
peu mais s'il la connaît très très bien
cramé elle avait l'air bien meilleur
pour les blancs Stéphane
qui avait dit ok c'était il y avait une
des très belles perspectives pour les
blancs tramnik a pu voir évidemment plus
loin ramener qu'il est capable de
transformer un petit avantage en gain
contre n'importe qui et surtout que dans
cette finale peut-être qu'elle soit on
se dit cramique la connaît par cœur et
moi pas trop ouais sur quoi après il se
dit si je fais fout.6 et bien les
cavaliers 5 et la cramique connaît par
cœur et moi pas du tout
de toute façon castor off de connaîtra
pas et cramique va connaître maintenant
Stéphane je crois qu'il y a coup de
bluff on peut le dire apparemment castor
fait sortie de sa préparation non c'est
pas ça
craque nous sort pour la première fois
ou la deuxième fois du match après la
deuxième partie une grosse préparation
blanche
que kasparoff n'avait pas n'a pas pu
anticiper encore une fois oh là là le
nom de la tête de gasparov
alors
maintenant si casse force se défend
on sait que il est extrêmement fort en
défense
donc il cherche la meilleure technique
on a vraiment l'impression de voir un
match Kasparov carpov à l'envers est
loin
Laurent le rôle de carpov c'est carpov
qui rendait les coups au maximum qui
profitait des imprécisions pour gagner
des parties
alors que c'est tout le jeu et là on a
l'impression que c'est l'inverse c'est
cramé qui fait tout le jeu c'est clair
et que ce parent qui rend les coups tant
qu'il peut
surprenant ce coup faut prendre 6 ce
serait la nouveauté du match aller
recommandé par l'ordinateur une fois de
plus à noter que l'ordinateur a quand
même mine de rien c'est énormément
progresser la théorie moderne Stéphane
oui c'est vrai faut bien le dire
personne n'y pense mais
l'ordinateur le propose à tempo ouais
c'est vrai c'est comme au bas de gamme
d'ailleurs si on peut faire une petite
analogie vite fait au backgammon depuis
que l'ordinateur existe et bien on joue
des coupes beaucoup moins positionnels
et beaucoup plus basé sur le sur les
probabilités sur le calcul
sa révolutionnait proprement le jeu de
backgamon alors qu'il y a des gens qui
passent devant la caméra là il faudrait
leur casser la gueule
pour ne plus qu'il le fasse Stéphane
demander à Yannick au grand mot les
grands moyens le ménage
et d'amener
toute la famille toute la famille toute
la partie
alors là
serait-il encore une fois mis en
difficulté par krani ce qui est beau
c'est chronique joue pour le gain dans
ce cas-là non mais c'est pas beau
Stéphane c'est normal la cramique il
veut il veut quand même marquer un autre
point il veut une sécurité comme ligue
il veut une sécurité
c'est toujours risqué mais justement
attention il est peut-être fatigué aussi
56 minutes est venu avec un préparateur
physique sous la barre en plus ça c'est
sûr il va être en hypnose il reste 56
minutes à gasparov pour jouer 26 coups
kasparo fait en train de se mettre tout
seul dans une grosse un gros problème
mais pourquoi il réfléchit il envisage
la finale et regarde le coup fous prends
un 6 qui avait de 5 voilà les deux
possibilités qui regardent il essaie de
comparer les deux il voit qu'il est
moins bien dans les deux il a l'air
fatigué qu'est-ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
est-ce que passeport ne pourrait pas
faire quand même cavalier prend M6
oui oui bah oui c'est la finale après
qui prend 6 c'est mais alors surtout
prends aussi voilà
peut-être un autre coup pour ces 7 quand
on sait cette Stéphane non je ne je ne
pense pas que ça puisse être c'est pas
possible pourquoi alors ton C7 on va le
regarder quand même c'est vrai que c'est
une proposition qui peut être pertinente
sur quoi la machine une fois de plus
nous vient en aide et propose le coût
possible Kavi G5
avant carrément pas mal qui avait déjà
F7 les fans et on peut pas prendre le
fou maintenant bah non parce qu'il y a
plus on prend non
ok
c'est ça bah oui comme ça c'est horrible
3 pièces avec échelle ah oui ah oui il y
avait caché de la dame
c'est cuit dur c'est cuit donc pas de
torse et 7 non mais on va revoir la
finale Stéphane je pense
plus pour les blancs mais il y a fout
pour l'instant
est-ce qu'on peut pas envisager plutôt
que d'un pronostic cavalier G5 plutôt
alors
attention on va revenir quand même voilà
ici est-ce qu'on peut pas envisager que
propose que j'ai très mauvais
quand même c'est possible
et la tour C7 c'est ça
avec deux fous contre une tour ça c'est
pas bon ça c'est pas bon
technique mais la position qui arrive
est très simple F3 là je pense qu'il
faut changer les dames pour éviter
d'avoir le roi faible on prend des 8
tours
peut-être plutôt celle-là je pense quand
même bon d'accord
et là nous nous sommes arrêtés là mais
ici il y a tout recettes avec un des
très belles perspectives pour les blancs
Stéphane je crois qu'il faut le dire non
soutenir la première non non il y a un
avantage blanc ici c'est un discutable
les géants
à mon avis il y a des bonnes chances de
transformer ça oh mais les pions doublés
quand même mais bon mettons-nous la
place de casparent quand même un petit
peu on peut pas gagner on peut pas
gagner cette finale jouer cette finale
c'est quand même pas la meilleure chose
qui peut lui arriver à La Garenne
sans perspective avec un plan de moins
où il est pas sûr de faire du mieux
c'est quand même pas c'est pas super non
non donc on va mettre
il y a de grandes chances d'arriver à
cette finale et sur fou prend F6 et bien
chronique peut augmenter la pression
voilà la position F6 on peut jouer 5
là c'est chaud chaud chaud
est en train de prendre l'avantage qu'on
castaro fait ça se voit par rapport au
temps et loi ça se voit par rapport au
temps effectivement n'a plus que 53
minutes pour jouer 26 coups ça commence
à être ça commence à être surprise
sévère comme on dit parce que quand il
va arriver vers les 30e
dans tous les sens
dans la préparation de kasparoff encore
une fois
casse-parents qui fait l'amour il ne
trouve pas
de coûts intéressants à jouer pour lui
il a le choix on va revenir à la
position
sur l'échiquier de démonstration voilà
il trouve pas il y a deux choix soit
cavaliers prend fou
soit fou prend fou alors on a vu que les
points fous qui mènent à cette finale
qui a l'air très difficile pour qu'elle
soit off et surtout prend fou surprenant
surprend fou voilà on voit que là
cramique pour jouer le coup peut-être
Cavalo 5 ou cavalier B5 à voir
tout de suite d'abord bien sûr Stéphane
qui attaque le pion à 7
tout à fait vise la case des 6 sur quoi
tour à vitesse
3 possible aussi
il a joué castor F6 non si non
ça laisse crannique jouer une finale
avec un point de plus sans aucun risque
faut pas aussi alors là on attend oui
alors là ça ça va être superbe
dernière
coup de massue c'est un moment très
chaud de la partie puisque la crânique
va prendre l'avantage
si il fait fout prend aussi ça il y a
pas des pas de il y a pas de bleu
il faut crameric prenne des mesures
radicales et directes il va jouer fous
aussi puis on prend d'un point aussi
c'est chèque oh chute d'un procès avec
cette fameuse finale assez complète
qu'on a bien détaillé tout à l'heure on
a vu toute la variante c'est un peu
c'est un peu compliqué mais ça marche il
y a une finale un petit peu avantageuse
pour les blancs finalement on rappelle
les lois une finale c'est une position
où il reste peu de pièces notamment où
les dames ont été échangées les dames
ont été échangées et donc les rois ne
risquent pas trop de grand chose et ce
qui décide de la finale en général c'est
la possibilité pour les pions d'aller à
dames c'est ça c'est le en fait c'est le
matériel restant sur l'échiquier donc ah
voilà
il va le faire attention
il nous a pas fait défaut comme la
dernière fois
va jouer tempo aussi sacrifice sacrifice
de chronique sacrifice de pièces
momentané Stéphane sacrifice quand même
sacrifice de pièces de krannique ça
c'est du gros jeu donc c'est des grosses
sport dans cette partie là Gary qui se
passe dans la boîte ça c'est sûr il est
pas bien attaque le pion F7 C8 il est où
là
il a failli mais il ne l'a pas fait il
veut bien calculer ouais c'est super
offre en plus il est mal au temple c'est
horrible
pour jouer 25 coups c'est très peu
puisqu'il est presque en dessous des
bilan en 2 minutes 2 minutes par coup si
on prend aussi il a joué aussi
cramique va prendre de la dame bien
entendu crâni rapide va récupérer une
deuxième pion pour le frein aussi échec
là normalement ouais je suis forcé
elle a réfléchi autant mais maintenant
il va débiter les coups puisque tout est
forcé alors là maintenant cramique
hésite avec
vous
cramique
qu'on a donné tout était prévu
voilà oui qu'est-ce-que là il est sûr
qu'on nique va réfléchir maintenant donc
c'est le calme après la tempête il y a
eu trois coups jouets consécutifs très
vite maintenant cramique on va montrer
montrons la position ici voilà c'est
celle-là on l'a déjà commenté tout à
l'heure cramique réfléchit il peut
échanger les dames il peut échanger les
dames pour reprendre tout de suite en F3
c'est les deux possibilités alors s'il
prend F3 évidemment crespor of prend le
pion des 4 avec la dame non mais ça
laisse trop de jaune noir contre le roi
blanc nous montrons cette position
voyons
six chronique fait pion prend F3
évidemment castor reprend le pion des
cartes de la dame et là on va voir que
en plus il y a le cavalier la dame ça me
sert
on a vu à l'oeuvre d'ailleurs dans la
partie de Sandy la partie ou kasporo a
sauvé miraculeusement mis
la partie
dernier pardon c'est la 6e partie voilà
donc ici c'est pas bon c'est pas bon non
non ça c'est pas bon il faut pas il faut
pas laisser la dame pourquoi bien
simplement parce que la structure autour
du roi blanc est démoli il faut donc
laisser le moins de chance d'attaque
possible notre logiquement dans cette
position il faut jouer d'un point il
faut d'abord échanger les dames pour
empêcher les Noirs d'avoir de l'attaque
contre le roi et après tout prendre
alors laquelle laquelle c'est à peu près
pareil de toute façon
avec un pion de plus deux fois plus pour
l'instant mais l'option des 4 protons
évidemment les Noirs forts et tout
reprendre les quatre et là que je
voulais blanc tout recettes ou cavalier
B5 donc ça a pas l'air bon il y a tout
retour des deux
voilà c'est sans doute la position qu'on
aura dans quelques coups parce que
cramique a pas vraiment de choix mais
enfin un joueur aussi subtil que cramer
qui peut quand même trouver des
surprises Stéphane
bon les blancs vont pas s'approcher
alors finalement 3 il va tomber ce pion
non non je pense pas pour que ce qui
devrait tomber
non on va jouer
c'est tout ce qui est autour du roi
blanc voilà c'est pions isolés parce
qu'ils sont ils sont démobilisés
difficiles à défendre mais il y a un
pion de plus pour les blancs et surtout
c'est au blanc de jouer
attaque le pion à 7
tours
sur la 7e ça c'est une c'est envisagée
évidemment ce serait une finale de tour
nul ça allait final le Tour sont toutes
nues les lois sauf celle qui sont
gagnantes
celles qui sont gagnants
alors c'est pas la position on va
revenir on va revenir la position c'est
celle-là ça c'est une variante mais
c'est très probablement ce que va
choisir de jouer cramique
à moins qu'il trouve autre chose
et peut pas jouer non il a une pièce de
moins il faut prendre
il faut prendre la dame pas le choix
pour cramique
pas le choix pas le choix notre choix
énorme il veut bien rentrer dans cette
finale il veut se mettre en condition
psychologique pour bien l'aborder
effectivement c'était pas évident de
casse pas en fait j'ai joué ça c'était
pas évident du tout maintenant on fait
son choix
à la finale en train de calculer les
coûts oh c'est clair mais ça sert à quoi
s'il est coup sont forcés autant les
jouer non non mais non mais il faut se
préparer mentalement faut se préparer
mentalement à cette finale parce que il
va y avoir un pion de plus ça va être
très dur à gagner c'est peut-être même
égal peut-être même nul en tout cas
rassemblement il a déroulé
tout est forcé ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il a réfléchit longtemps et puis
maintenant il y va a priori Kia sport
off c'est ce qui se passe il comprend
bien ce qu'il est en train de se passer
parce qu'on va jouer cavalier H5 après
dans le public un petit portable encore
qui a dû sonner ou peut-être il cherche
à voir si un de ces seconds et dans la
salle
moi je sais pas je ce type de finale que
j'aimerais pas jouer ça va pas l'air
facile à jouer
pas facile pour les Noirs en tout cas ça
c'est sûr bon cramique qui risque rien
lui il est hyper tranquille puisqu'il
est un peu plus actif il a un demi tour
de plus oui mais les Noirs
c'est ça
et là je pense qu'il faut analyser un
peu plus en détail après tout recettes
voilà la position critique que les
joueurs ont probablement dans quelques
coups et là il faut bien regarder toutes
les possibilités pour les blancs et pour
les Noirs il y en a beaucoup des
possibilités ici
alors là on arrive on pourrait pas jouer
de tour des deux
d'abord
il y a un petit problème pourquoi après
tour des deux c'est simplement le coup
non on prendrait le pion à 7 contre le
pion des deux B2
avec finale quand même je sais pas moi
j'ai l'impression que les Noirs vont
pouvoir attaquer le roi blanc alors que
le noir
non ce qu'on peut pas envisager dans
cette position je me demande mais ça
laisse le pion B2 non on récupère à 7
pour doubler les tours sur la 7e c'est
ça
on jouerait éventuellement tout
reprendre B2
incroyable
G7 donc j'ai 8 ou bien tout même tour F2
peut-être un tour G8 avec des bonnes
choses c'est vrai que les finales de
Tours sont souvent nuls non on va voir
droit et non moi je vois pas comment
grandir voilà la position bon la
position c'est celle-là
cette finale est nulle chronique va être
obligé de rentrer de cette finale et les
Noirs vont tirer la Nil c'est assez
facilement finalement aujourd'hui
pareil il est rentré dans le match là il
est bien chaud maintenant c'est sûr non
moi je vois pas comment cramique peut
espérer avoir le moindre avantage cette
finale avec les pions doublés les tours
le cavalier noir qui menace d'être plus
dangereux que le Cavalier Blanc donc il
va falloir les changer probablement ou
essayer de les changer c'est pas sûr que
les Noirs acceptent en plus de les
changer est-ce que les Noirs ne
pourraient pas même jouer pour le gain
étant donné la faiblesse du roi blanc
non non
Stéphane il faut pas non plus exagérer
ici les Blancs ont un plan de plus ils
sont une position active non non il
risque rien les bureaux cramiques ne
risquent rien pour l'instant il est en
train de dominer tranquille
une nulle de plus ça serait la réponse
ça ne serait que la 8e consécutive c'est
pas
aux échecs nous on en fait que 8 non non
mais ça serait étonnant qui est autant
nul c'est vrai que je champion du monde
c'est rare c'est de la dernière le
dernier a pas vu c'était contre un Inde
ouais le dernier contrairement on
pensait avoir établi un record avec
Winnie le consécutif dans les premières
mais après ça ensuite
c'est une partie
une nul qu'est-ce qu'on regagne de suite
et une quatrième après effectivement
donc ça a chauffé ça a chauffé le feu au
match apparemment il y aurait un
spectateur peut-être un parapsychologue
de Kasparov qui serait en train de
troubler cramique
trop facile qui a planning la position
quand il veut
Stéphane peut-être qu'on peut recadrer
un peu l'ambiance de ces format d'échec
de ces championnats du monde notamment
peut-être qui a commencé avec le match
carpov cocheneuil à Baggio en
62 le 60 quelque chose 78 78 ça doit
être ça ou korchon il accusé carpov
d'avoir empoisonné ses yaourts ou ce
genre de ce genre de choses il y a eu
tout un climat comme ça aussi avec
Fisher ou les champions sont
effectivement complètement parano
complètement dingue et c'est normal
puisque effectivement le top niveau
c'est un peu ça aux échecs il y a
beaucoup de joueurs quand même non mais
il y a un peu de il y a un peu de
superstition aussi beaucoup de joueurs
particuliers on va dire
pas du tout de problème d'ailleurs il a
fait aucune difficulté lui par rapport
au choix de choix de chaise de choix de
chaise par exemple il a pas du tout
ticket il a pris celle qu'on lui
proposer qui est très bien
c'est des histoires pour sa chaise
là cramique va-t-il rentrer dans cette
finale
chronique va sûrement rentrer dans cette
finale après dame Paname
et ensuite il va prendre F3 et on va
avoir droit
alors que Théo va nous quitter et oui
Théo qui est là pour la télévision
française
Suisse et Suisse aussi
voilà
donc là
va-t-il jouer tout de suite d'apprendre
à moi c'est quasiment sûr mais va
réfléchir un peu cramique mais
tranquille
on va avoir droit à une nul assez
rapidement je pense
oui tout à fait
on va encore avoir droit probablement
une nul aujourd'hui malgré son pion de
plus crâni ne pourra probablement pas
gagner cette finale
il prend son temps cramique avant de
jouer son cou
est-ce qu'il va jouer et puis on prend
un fou
j'y crois pas à ce coup-là c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible
ça serait
beaucoup trop risqué
beaucoup trop
quoique on sait jamais avec Rami
ah peut-être cramine pour jouer pion
prend fou et après dans prendre des cas
cavalier 4 c'est possible
c'est possible
mais ça a pas l'air bon ça n'a pas l'air
bon du tout
quoi que apprécie si après qu'il y avait
des points
et puis
et puis et puis c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair c'est pas clair ce que
peut jouer cramer dans cette position
et oui puis on prend F3 à l'air possible
puis on prend F3 a l'air possible
crânique va-t-il mettre le feu les chic
et un jour pion prend F3
c'est possible parce que il pourrait
profiter du fait que ça dame est bien
implantée dans le camp noir ça peut être
un motif
d'attaque un type de jeu
et c'est pas exclu c'est pas exclu que
chronique
je joue cette finale de cette façon
avec ma foi
et bien
des complications et on n'aurait pas
droit dans ce cas-là une nulle rapide on
aura droit du jeu mais de gros risques
du côté blanc puisque le côté le roi
serait quand même en position délicate
Laurent se rend position délicate mais
c'est envisageable
on ne peut pas exclure cette possibilité
puis on prend fou et après dame prend
des quatre bien peut-être
cavalier C3 bouges en E4 voir en dessin
c'est risqué mais c'est possible
c'est possible
je vous rappelle on est au 17e coup et
là après des échanges de pièces
cramique réfléchit à la possibilité
de rentrer dans une finale où il est
très légèrement mieux mais c'est
probablement nul une finale de tour
où les Noirs arriveraient sans trop de
difficultés à tirer la nul
et ce serait donc un nouveau coup dans
l'eau pour granny
cette partie
et pourquoi ce Parrot aussi
surtout pour Kasparov qui est mené au
score
et qui maintenant doit avoir passé des
parties avec un peu d'angoisse puisque
chaque partie qui
vous cramique fait nul et bien c'est
leur approche du titre ça leur approche
de du gain du match
alors là là là là
réflexion là de cramique
chronique à fond dans le match
je rappelle qu'il reste 51 minutes à
castor pour jouer 23 coups
contre
37 minutes
pardon une heure 23 cramique
qui donc
a une demi-heure d'avance sur castor
alors attention
gros danger
c'est une cramique fait pion prend fou
et joue pour le gain mais
ça a l'air quand même
d'être très risqué puis on prend fou
d'en prendre des quatre
et les pièces noires vont probablement
attaquer le roi blanc
qui va être un peu en l'air
c'est très peu probable comme il va
sûrement échanger les dames
ça serait quand même
trop dangereux de faire puis on prend
fou
quoi que après d'en prendre des quatre
puis on prend froid donc
et bien c'est possible
cramique fait pion prend fou et oui ça y
est et oui effectivement chronique joue
pour le gain et bien on a droit à du
grand crâni encore une fois puis on
prend fou
étonnant crinding ne rentre pas dans la
finale qui lui qui allait probablement
être nul mais il joue pour l'avantage et
après puis on prend fou il casse pas on
va répondre pardon et cramique sûrement
prévu la riposte cavalier B5 pour venir
en D6 voilà peut-être l'idée voilà
prendre des cartes de casse pas off
waouh c'est chaud
d'en prendre des cartes de casse-parents
et là cramique
que je veux cramique c'est la question
waouh
qu'est-ce que c'est chaud
c'est chaud ce que je veux cramer c'est
super chaud
c'est très dangereux ce que je veux
cramique sans roi
et dans les courants d'air et cramique
joue quand même pour le gain c'est
incroyable
parce que fait cramique
il joue pour le spectacle alors que
ah là là là là là
c'est super chaud c'est super chaud
crânique a pris le fou d'abord il a pas
échangé les dames et donc il joue pour
le gain alors que son roi est en grande
difficulté
le roi de granit qui est en l'air si
vous voyez la position et bien les pions
du vent devant le roi blanc
ici sont très
mal placé le roi n'est plus protégé donc
les Noirs vont pouvoir attaquer ce roi
mais chronique a estimé que il s'en
attaque va percer d'abord sûrement c'est
ce qu'il a estimé c'est un moment très
important de la partie chronique va
jouer probablement le coup cavalier sur
la case B5 voilà si je peux montrer
voilà le cavalier en C3 peut-être va
venir sur la case B5 attaquant la dame
et ensuite s'infiltrer dans la camomille
probablement sur la caisse des 6 et de
la et oui oui c'est ce qu'a fait
cramique effectivement cavalier B5 voilà
l'idée de cramique waouh c'est chaud
mais là les noirs peuvent prendre le
pion B2
voilà c'est chaud
après ce que cramique ce serait de pas
trompé dans cette variante
si c'est trompé ça va se savoir tempo
comme on dit aux échecs tempo
dans la seconde
très risqué ce qu'a fait
très très risqué
casse pas off peut jouer la
contre-attaque et on sait qu'il est très
fort dans la contre-attaque qui se part
en
il peut menacer des maths contre le roi
blanc qui est faible
notamment s'il arrive à mettre son
cavalier noir sur la case F4
c'est chaud c'est super chaud alors je
change de micro
voilà ici
castaroff s'il arrive à positionner son
cavalier
sur la case par exemple en passant par
chien sur la case F4 et bien ce cavalier
serait monstrueux puisqu'il contrôlerait
les cases E2 et G2 empêchant le roi
blanc de partir
si on peut montrer l'échiquier
démonstration
voilà parcours du cavalier possible
caviage 5 survie de kaoli F4
mais les Blancs ont aussi une attaque et
j'aurais cavaliers eux sur la case D6
voilà le cavalier B5 viendrait sur la
case des 6 attaquant la tour C8 et
attaquant la case F7 avait des échecs
possibles dans le noir
donc il y a des achats des deux côtés
ou noir
au revoir Théo qui nous quitte
et qui est venu à Londres pour la
télévision française
c'est très chaud attaque et
contre-attaque et
on se demande ce qui passait par la tête
de cramique car l'ordinateur donne
avantage au noir dans cette position
qu'est-ce que il se passe mais c'est pas
sûr évidemment cramique est très fort il
est plus fort que l'ordinateur ça c'est
clair
il n'y a pas de bluff
il y a pas de bluff
c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est risqué c'est très risqué que
ça fait chronique ça c'est certain
il joue pour le gain mais si il passe
bien évidemment il gagne le jackpot
signe des très grands champions
c'est
chronique a joué cette variante c'est
bien c'est qu'il a estimé
il a calculé il a estimé qu'il était
mieux
mais ça paraît extrêmement extrêmement
dangereux
les Noirs ayant la possibilité de mettre
le roi blanc sous pression
va falloir être très précis pour cramer
la moindre faute sera sanctionnée par la
victoire des Noirs dans cette ville dans
cette partie c'est terrible ce qui est
en train de se passer
on a tous
c'est chaud
c'est super chaud
et c'est super chaud ici les lois
puisque cramique a pris le fou n'a pas
échangé les dames
et il a joué le coup qui a l'air à
double tranchant cavaler B5 menaçant
probablement de venir sur la case B6 ah
ouais effectivement je vois un chemin
très très explicite avec l'ordinateur
donne avantage au nom
si avantage au noir et oui l'ordinateur
donne avantage au noir avec un point
d'avance mais on sait très bien que dans
ce type de position au blanc Stéphane
blanc mais ça a l'air très dangereux
quand même pour les Noirs moi j'aurais
eu peur à la place de cramique et
kasparoff a des possibilités de
contre-attaques probablement sur le roi
blanc ouais non mais ce qui est tout à
fait ce qui est tout à fait bien dans la
position de cramique une seconde il faut
rationner un peu les informations aussi
c'est que des six c'est une grosse
menace en fait c'est peut-être le roi de
Kasparov qui serait plus faible que le
renard alors bon là il y a vous voyez
beaucoup de choses mais en fait une fois
qu'on a enlevé ce qui n'est pas
essentiel
c'est à dire tout ça
c'est comme quand on enlève la pub dans
Marie Claire il reste plus grand chose
on voit chiquer de démonstration donc
on va faire attaquer par Marie Claire
qui raconte du petit Laurent fasciné
de démonstration parce que là il y a une
variante très intéressante
voilà voilà une fois qu'on a enlevé le
superflu il ne reste plus que
l'essentiel c'est le cas et B5 qui
attaque la Dame des 4 qui va bondir en
D6 puis en F7 et c'est le roi de castrov
qui le premier sera sous le feu des
échecs puisque après on peut envisager
que la dame revienne sur la case aussi
c'est avec le fameux matelet tout fait
Stéphane qui menacera et alors que ouais
non mais en fait ouais c'est super
cramique a vu plus loin une fois de plus
il faut pas se laisser intoxiquer par la
faible formation des pions blancs il
défendent très très bien en fait le roi
blanc et c'est le roi de Gary castrov
qui est en danger après ce coup qui est
M5 première remarque déjà sur ton
français il y a d'un point fuite il y a
une tour enfin il y a tout
oui mais bien sûr c'est les noirs
fuite avec échec et ensuite on prend la
dame noire et ensuite on prend la dame
noire
pas facile pour Gary
coupe aussi pour regarder
ou intéressant en tout cas puisque ça
contrôle la case F7 ça c'est important
bon il donne des cinq salaires pas mal
ça contre-attaque sur F3 mais ici donc
on jouerait
le coup qui est
chassant la tour puisqu'on l'attaque on
ne sait pas trop où cette tour peut
aller par exemple imaginons qu'elle
aille sur la 4G vite faute on se
prendrait directement à ma télé
donc la tour n'a pas beaucoup de cas
c'est bien sur la case 8 on se prend le
mettre du couloir alors
échec tours échec dame j'ai vite et là
je vais te forcer et là boum cavalier
voilà tout à fait et bien est-ce que
cramique nous ferait pas une petite
potion
et je crois que non
de l'aluminium et dans le four
ce qui nous ferait un castor off aller
tout fait
après
on peut le dire Gary il est cuit et
après deux bulles il ne pourra plus
revenir et là c'est quand même super
c'est quand même vraiment super
il va y passer Gary
il va y avoir droit
le petit passeport non non mais là c'est
je crois que les Blancs quand même c'est
très risqué
ce qu'ils ont fait cramique aurait pu
prendre la nul avec la finale et là il
prend tous les risques chroniques
donc deux choses l'une
soit ça passe ça veut dire qu'il est
très très fort et qu'il est à le carreur
d'un champion du monde ou alors ça passe
pas et ça veut dire que
qu'est-ce qu'on revienne dans le match
et ça relance tout
alors tout de suite ne peut pas perdre
mais il y a quand même
l'ordinateur donnerait
la structure et un demi tour de plus
pour l'initiative
c'est très peu ah oui mais à la fin si
tout est changé avec le pion doublé qui
serait vraiment bien de plus non mais je
vois pas comment casse-prof peut aller
en finale dans cette position il ne peut
pas aller en finale il y a sport donc il
va se prendre une il va se prendre une
grosse attaque il se prend déjà une
grosse attaque là
ah oui parce que là on voit sur les
coups blancs il y a très peu de perte de
temps tout de suite on attaque la dame
ensuite on joue sur ton tour contour qui
est ici on attaque encore la tour
après
ça veut dire que on va déplacer la dame
le roi et la tournoi et nous on va
s'améliorer à chaque fois non ici il est
pas bien il est pas bien il a dû se dire
tout simplement quelque chose alors que
Stéphane je crois que
quelque chose arrive
ça y est
nous voilà donc de nouveau toujours en
direct studio sur diagonale sur canal
web
il est complètement dominé par Vladimir
cramique pour l'instant rappelons dans
le match il est mené 5 à 4 après 9
parties c'est la dixième qui est en
train de se jouer actuellement et Gary
castor of pour l'instant un pion de
moins une position mauvaise et 40
minutes de retard c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
reste que 40 minutes il reste 1h20 donc
à deux fois plus de temps de gaz par an
ils ont joué 19 coups donc dois-je jouer
ses coups plus vite que deux minutes par
coup il est sous pression et c'est très
très difficile sachant que si il perd ça
fera un score de 6 à 4 et kramix sera à
deux points et demi de la victoire deux
points et demi c'est pas beaucoup
de points de vie de la victoire finale
du titre champion du monde voilà un
bilan pendule et que ça donne noir juste
devant mais il reste bien 1h20 à
Vladimir cramnique contre 40 minutes à
Kasparov
on peut le dire Gary est très très mal
il est en train de réfléchir il s'est
fait planter une préparation par
Vladimir cramique et maintenant il
atterrit dans cette position qu'on va
vous remonter
la position si on peut la revoir en
vidéo sur l'échiquier de démonstration
la voilà
Vladimir
de Stéphane
qui ne s'est absenté que très peu de
temps finalement je crois puisqu'il est
déjà de retour en fait
il est vraiment très rapide
il est vraiment à droite une grosse
partie aujourd'hui les lois et là ça
faisait un moment qu'on attendait
alors à noter Stéphane quand même que
non
autant pour moi non mais une petite
seconde voilà je vais voilà c'est tout
ce que tu auras
puisque rappelons que nous avons chacun
nos stocks
respectifs
alors non mais là j'ai été interrompu
Stéphane j'étais en train de mentionner
quelque chose de très intéressant quand
tu es revenu Direct Sport aurait joué
dame pro B2
pendant que nous étions un peu distrait
et tout de suite l'ordinateur retourne
au sa veste
non non je rigole
ne me prends B2 il faut jouer alors on
peut peut-être voir la position ramener
que serein toujours on va montrer la
position
il faut montrer la position sur sur
l'échiquier de démonstration
un ticket de démonstration le mot
magique ne fonctionne plus voilà ça y
est d'un premier 2 tours
effectivement il n'y a pas un zéro c'est
purement fictif
Stéphane tu me fais faire n'importe quoi
ce n'est pas grave on le verra plus tard
quel est des six dans cette position
voilà c'est le c'est le coup ennuyeux
attaque la tour à 8 7 tours doit bouger
peut-être venir sur la case à 8 et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on ferait et
bien Stéphane je crois que là il y a le
réseau non est-ce qu'on peut pas dire
qu'il y a le réseau là
ça a l'air embêtant mais en tout cas une
chose est sûre c'est que c'est du blanc
qui attaque là quand même oui mais il y
a il y a au moins nul pour les blancs
si vous ne rejoignez
voilà
donc là
en grande réflexion
bon voilà donc
c'est aussi ce qu'il faut faire en
défense
oui non mais Stéphane c'est ridicule par
exemple sur
ne peut pas jouer dans des deux ah non
mais non la dame
cette
moi j'arrive pas à croire
ce type d'attaque là on sait jamais
comment on a terminé
il va falloir prendre ses 8
tours c'est très propre
je vois pas comment
mais du coup il s'enlève des
possibilités d'attaque contre le roi
blanc
parce que là maintenant on fait 100 % en
France
c'est sûr
que va jouer avec
contrôle le cavalier et le pion G7 ça
peut avoir un important
bon à quoi réfléchit ramnic ça ça
m'énerve
alors tout le couteau prend ses 8 a
l'air tu en pensez vite à l'air forcé
puisque sinon les blancs perdent le
temps dans l'attaque ils s'aèrent mais
non mais de toute façon le cahier B5 qui
est en prison
on peut le faire
on peut le faire il y aurait dame
français
ici est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
possibilités je ne crois pas il faut
jouer ton pantou retournable et après
8 elle a pas l'air bon tout va vite il
est très bon après
déjà il peut faire une nouvelle lumière
mais il y a des choses il y a des choses
intéressantes non mais là il fait
attention parce que par exemple un truc
comme key et F7 échec Roger 8 et qui est
D8 ça crée des menaces supplémentaires
ça crée de la mossis avec le mat elle
étouffée
on a coupé la tour du truc c'est très
intéressant comme merci
c'est terminé c'est toujours délicat ce
genre d'attaque
dès que les Noirs jouent à 6 il y a plus
jamais de maths
les possibilités en fait non mais ça va
être nul
chronique a essayé d'attaquer mais non
je pense pas que ce soit aussi facile
pour garer
on ne voit pas comment les blancs à
moins d'une imprécision des Noirs ce qui
peut ce qui peut avoir lieu par contre
après les décises il semble que la tour
soit obligé d'aller en A8 où j'ai vite
non après tout on s'est vite on s'est
vite et la tour n'a pas de case non
vraisemblablement cramique a l'air plus
ou moins obligé de jouer ça ouais on va
le mention
la tour n'a pas beaucoup de cases il
faut aller en à 8 c'est la seule elle
est super mal placée la tour là
et c'est complètement
là est-ce que cramique peut jouer un
coup comme cavalier F5 et loi
installons un cavalier Kia sport off
installant un cavalier Kasparov ad vitam
eternam contre Kasparov et que faire
parce que si on joue
vite non seulement l'ordinateur avec
petit avantage noir
c'est vrai que après qui est j'évite la
dame revient en défense en F6
les pièces blanches oui c'est l'attaque
et les c'est quand même douteux moi je
non mais bon on peut faire une quand ils
veulent Stéphane ouais peut-être non
mais ça c'est sûr
en tout cas chronique on va essayer il a
pas fait il est pas entrer dans la
finale qu'il faisait nul de toute façon
quasi sûr il a essayé de monter une
attaque c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à voir
les chances de Vladimir Candy ici
alors que la Corse s'en va
et reviens-nous vite
merci Yannick
il est payé
et c'est bien normal
alors donc là
tout reprendre tout alors Stéphane toi
tu envisagerais que les jours fasses
nulle tout de suite en fait comme ça
que font les blancs
c'est pas effectivement
nul par
appétitivité de trouver des choses mais
trouver quoi
il est obligé de mater directement il
peut par exemple aller piquer un pion
quelque part
ouais mais il a déjà perdu un pion B2 il
y a déjà égalité de pions les Nord ont
peut-être un gobé un deuxième
les pions blancs du côté noir sont
faibles après c'est les noirs qui
risquent d'être dangereux alors puis on
passe
à se défendre on voit même défendre
peut-être les Noirs prennent l'avantage
donc
impression que là pour mais bon de
l'autre côté on gagne pas d'attaque de
façon trop non plus linéaire
il faut il faut tenter des choses la
chronique à tenter des choses bon
pourquoi pas et là casse pas il lui
reste 39 minutes à castor off contre
1h10 à cramique donc quand même petite
avantage au temps à cramique la
chronique réfléchit la possibilité comme
les D6 ou bien tourpentour
faut rappeler que bon notre ordinateur
aussi mais on a bien vu plusieurs fois
que il voit pas tout c'est vrai passer
un certain nombre
le fameux effet d'horizon fameux effet
d'horizon il peut pas calculer au-delà
d'un certain nombre de coups parce que
ça fait trop de possibilités
et pour progresser d'un coup
quand on est déjà au dixième coup de
réflexion par exemple pour progresser
d'un coup ça demande tellement d'effort
qu'il faudrait plusieurs jours à
l'ordinateur pour y arriver et c'est à
dire que pour passer d'un coup un micro
de micro suivant il faut multiplier la
réflexion par 20 donc
20 x 10 minutes voilà tout simplement
voilà pour 20 fois 10 minutes pour voir
un couple plus loin donc l'ordinateur
est limité dans sa profondeur de calcul
parce qu'il est il calcule tout est
possible
alors que lui-même et lui l'humain le
crânique
le crânique lui n'est pas limité dans
ses possibilités il est limité
différemment calcul en termes de
surtout limité par stratégie par le
temps tout le temps physique
par le stress par les enjeux
mais sinon évidemment l'humain calcule
quand même mieux que l'ordinateur
avec des oublis de temps en temps mais
pas beaucoup plus loin en règle générale
chronique là il a l'air serein de toute
façon cramé il risque rien il est
peinard il a une position égalité
matérielle c'est lui qui a l'attaque il
est en train d'attaquer Kasparov il est
sous pression parce que n'oublions pas
que la gaffe arrive vite ouais mais
enfin là on va pas trop trop parce qu'il
va il va rester très peu de pions
probablement
et après une fois que ce pion est
terminé il suffit que les Noirs se
défendent et c'est terminé
il est mort peuvent même gagner la
partie
en poussant leur pion passé
donc
enfin bon les blancs au moins une
attaque avec des échecs perpétuels c'est
sûr ça c'est clair donc de toute façon
il y a au moins la nul pour les blancs
et peut-être peut-être petit avantage
tout petit rikiki l'avantage des blancs
s'il existe un petit rikiki
il faut pas perdre de temps si on fait
caler des 6 et bien on se heurte
à des problèmes
on est là
il y a pas de gain en tout cas c'est
clair il y a pas de gain immédiat
il n'y a pas de gain immédiat et si
non je crois que c'est clair je crois
que c'est clair il n'y a pas de gain
en tout cas on en trouve pas il y a pas
de gars c'est pas pour ça qu'il y en a
pas ouais non mais après il faut que
faut trouver une contre-attaque quelque
part il faut prendre les pions delda ou
je sais pas ouais c'est ça il faut les
pions
prennent pas les pions
ça suffira pas le cavalier Adam se
firont pas le renard est défendu
lui-même par un cavalier une dame
si c'est la dame B2 qui porte une en
défense à tout moment et donc on voit
mal on voit mal on voit mal comment les
blancs pourrait
passer passeront pas tout de suite
cramique qui fait
il se rend compte que ça passe pas
moi ça serait étonnant que ça passe ça
veut dire que la variante serait
gagnante pour les blancs
oui ça voudrait dire ça mais
ça doit être surprenant
je ne sais pas Stéphane il faudra lui
demander la confiance de presse
peut-être
le
on dirait qu'il s'endort un peu non mais
c'est clair que il faut qu'il calcule
tout parce que la moindre erreur
l'avantage blanc n'existe plus
si
il doit mettre la pression sur le
Kasparov c'est
sans se tromper à aucun moment
qui a pris le pion mais quand même ça
c'est bien joué
non seulement ça prend un pion mais en
plus la dame est bien en défense sur
cette quasi fallait pas se précipiter
sur l'échec en G5 qui apporte rien
des fautes voilà donc ça c'est une
possibilité qu'on envisageait la Dame
Blanche serait venue prendre l'option à
7 donc voilà une position que cramique
peut avoir c'est à dire dans cette
position et le roi dame B7 la tour
reviendra dans la fuite et d'un franc à
conserverait donc un point le plus mais
ça on n'y croit pas trop parce que là
c'est casse pas qui commencerait
peut-être à pouvoir trouver des chances
la casse pas off tout de suite il peut
il peut elle peut jouer aussi
et puis ça y est HS plus rien mais sans
roi après il bouge son cavalier et après
ils sont Cali menace de venir en H5 F4
non ça c'est pas prometteur pour
cramique ça ne va pas
rappelons quand même que chronique peut
trouver des solutions donc la position
pour l'instant c'est celle-ci
peut trouver des choses mais on a
vraiment du mal à voir quoi là quand
même Stéphane
mais on voit pas comment il peut nous
surprendre mais on voit pas comment mais
bon jusqu'à présent c'est quand il nous
a surpris c'est qu'on justement n'avait
pas vu c'est vrai que la surprise vient
du fait qu'on n'est pas vu
mais sinon on aurait pas été surpris si
on l'avait vu en fait exactement
par définition même de la surprise
nous surprend c'est qu'on aura pas vu
alors là
il réfléchit toujours chronique
il faut c'est chaud c'est très chaud
everything
d'affilée
oui ce qui veut dire que en principe
comme en Russie même les
comment dire enfin tout le monde joue
très très bien aux échecs tout le monde
peut apprécier même des nuls il y a pas
besoin de choses spectaculaires c'est
vrai enfin quand même il y avait une
certaine lassitude qui s'instaurait
au bout de trois mois et demi de jeu
quand on a fait la 30e consécutive et
bien ça commençait à être un peu fatigué
j'ai pas besoin de 10 cases une seule
suffit
et après on pourrait rejouer d'un
musette et proposer nul à tout moment
chronique peut faire nul mais de toute
façon
donc pas de souci de ce côté-là
pas mal quand même tu as trouvé ce
trouvé crâne puis on prend fou et pas
d'en prendre
ouais c'est vrai c'était intéressant
très intéressant ouais il cherche
chronique mais on a l'impression que il
peut chercher longtemps
et pas grand chose à trouver alors
peut-être Stéphane qu'il faut quand même
changer de cassette
pour éviter de rater la fin de cette
partie ah oui peut-être changer de
cassette effectivement puisqu'on va
arriver au bout c'est ça voilà c'est ça
on va aller au bout on va changer de
cassette pour l'enregistrement au cas où